com live bei bild am sonntagabend 21 45
mit dem mann der cdu parteichef werden
will um dann später kanzler zu werden
schönen guten abend begrüßte sie hat
sich in meiner heimat was ist in einem
jahr los ungefähr um den eigenen oder um
diese zeit werden wir wahrscheinlich die
bundestagswahl haben oder eine woche
vorher schon die bundestagswahl das
heißt hier überall in ganz deutschland
wird möglicherweise wenn es so läuft wie
sie es wollen ihr gesicht plakatiert
werden schauen wir mal was könnte da
passt ja mal ganz wenig text drauf was
könnte oder was sollte aus ihrer meinung
nach ungefähr draufstehen zukunft
zukunft sie stehen für die zukunft das
würde ich jedenfalls für die cdu in
anspruch nehmen ja es gab eine
interessante veranstaltung am wochenende
in niedersachsen wo sie gesprochen haben
nämlich bei der jungen union friedrich
merz war dort zu gast und wenig später
ein paar stunden später auch armin
laschet ihr vielleicht schärfster
konkurrent im rennen um den cdu vorsitz
und auch er hat sich darüber geäußert
wie er sich die zeit nach angela merkel
versteht
er sagt kein bruch mit merkel soll es
geben
sehen sie das genauso wie er wir sind
uns da völlig einig und es gibt aus
meiner sicht auch überhaupt keinen grund
dass immer wieder zu wiederholen
das klang von dem jahr ganz anders da
haben sie kritisiert die kanzlerin für
ihre untätigkeit sie haben ihr mangelnde
führung vorgeworfen sie haben gesagt die
regierung sei grottenschlecht verweise
ich habe alles anderes erscheinungsbild
der regierung sei grottenschlecht und
das war es auch
das war die zeit unmittelbar nach der
thüringen wahl ganz genau aber sie haben
ja keine 30 prozent ja mangelnde führung
und hier und wenn sie jetzt mal aus
jüngerer zeit zitate von mir nehmen
würden dann würden sie auch finden und
zwar fast täglich dass ich sage die
bundesregierung führt uns gut durch
diese krise ganz genau was ist in einem
jahr passiert das ist die kleine krise
dass sich ihr bild auch von der
kanzlerin wieder verändert hat von der
regierung verändert das bild ja ganz des
ganzen landes hat sich vollkommen
verändert die lage hat sich völlig
verändert und diese regierung führt man
muss nicht mit allem einverstanden sein
dass die bundesregierung im augenblick
tut da werden wir noch darauf zu
sprechen kommen aber ich finde man kann
im augenblick wirklich sagen die
bundesregierung auch die
landesregierungen übrigens auch die in
nordrhein westfalen von armin laschet
führen dieses land gut durch die krise
noch mal auf diesen satz kein bruch mit
merkel den laster zeigt das heißt den
unterstützen sie das kann er doch aber
viel besser als die kontinuität der
kommt doch aus dem merkel lager
wozu braucht es na ja also kein bruch
und kontinuität sind ja zwei
verschiedene kategorien also ich sage
wir werden im nächsten jahr eine ära
abschließen von 16 jahren die die
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel dieses
land geführt und geprägt hat und wir
werden dann in eine neue zeit gehen und
wir werden den blick nach vorn richten
also sie sind dann der der für eine neue
ausrichtung nach merkels das
habe ich immer wieder so gesagt habe ich
auch an diesem wochenende in hildesheim
bei der jungen union niedersachsen so
gesagt wir müssen eine antwort geben auf
die herausforderungen unserer zeit und
wir müssen eine antwort geben wo dieses
jahr denn in zehn jahren stehen soll wir
werden nicht aus dankbarkeit gewählt für
die zeit die zurückliegt sondern wir
werden gewählt wenn wir eine
zukunftsvorstellung haben vielleicht hat
eine vision von unserer zukunft und wenn
wir antworten geben auf die fragen die
uns heute gestellt sind sagen sie einst
konkret vielleicht auch vom stil was
sich da ändern könnte also wer dann für
den der sich vielleicht auch nicht jeden
tag mit politik beschäftigt sofort
erkennbar h der märz der macht wirklich
anders das ist eine neuausrichtung
naja was sie wollen immer auf die
unterschiede heraus jeder hat seinen
eigenen führungsstil bringt seine
eigenen erfahrungen mit
natürlich wird jeder auch dieses land
egal wer nächstes jahr bundeskanzler
wird anders prägen anders führen als
angela merkel das getan hat
wenn sie mich nach meiner persönlichen
sicht und meinen persönlichen stil
fragen
ich möchte sichtbar werden lassen welche
kompetenzen wir dann außer demjenigen
der die partei führt gegebenenfalls das
land noch haben
ich würde gerne die cdu breit aufstellen
auch in den themen die themen mit
gesichtern verbinden und auch einfach
das personal von unten erkennbar werden
dass wir eine tolle junge leute in der
bundestagsfraktion
davon müssen einige sichtbar werden
gibt's eine andere sprache
direkte ansprache mehr ansprache
vielleicht mehr direkte ansprache mehr
klartext sind noch einmal gar nicht in
abgrenzung zur angela merkel sie hat
fähigkeiten die ich nicht habe ich habe
fähigkeiten die sie nicht hat ich würde
gerne mehrere erklären ich denke dass
die politik in den nächsten jahren noch
mehr erklären muss wo wir eigentlich die
themen sehen
ich verwende schon seit geraumer zeit
mindestens zwei drittel meiner reden
meine redezeit auf die erklärung der
lage das ist nicht alles selbsterklärend
und die welt in der wir leben ändert
sich rasant schnell die bevölkerung hat
einen anspruch darauf dass die politik
erklärt wie sie das sieht sie haben
gerade gesagt
sie hat fähigkeiten die sie nicht haben
und umgekehrt ganz genauso welche
fähigkeit wünschen sie sich denn von
formate na ja sie hat unglaublich gute
nerven ich glaube die habe ich auch ob
ich sie so gut habe wie sie weiß ich
nicht sie ist unglaublich beherrscht in
ihren arbeiten in ihrem tun sehr
diszipliniert ich glaube das bin ich
auch ob es so war jetzt weiß ich nicht
aber etwas ziemlich gut aber so sie ist
sie ist sicherlich erfahren über lange
jahre in der regierung und noch mal
sie hat die begabung selbst im größten
sturm völlig ruhig zu bleiben da bin ich
wahrscheinlich ein stück emotionaler
schauen wir uns einmal foto an aus
vergangenen tagen das war die phase als
sie sich dann vorübergehend aus der
politik verabschiedet haben als sie den
fraktionsvorsitz abgegeben haben sie
immer gleich das foto sie erinnern sich
natürlich bestens an diese zeit was
glauben sie wer angela merkel heute in
dem rennen um den parteivorsitz
eigentlich unterstützt das weiß ich
nicht ich habe eine gewisse ahnung aber
die spielt im grunde genommen jetzt für
mich und ich glaube auch für große teile
der partei keine rolle
das ist schon wichtig wichtig zu wissen
also es wäre durch eine hätte eine welle
gegeben wenn sie es gesagt hätte weiß
gar nicht ob es positiv oder negativ
gewesen werden sie vermuten dass sie für
armin laschet na ja also ich sag mal so
sie ist in bayern gewesen und hat sich
vom bayerischen ministerpräsidenten
einladen das versuche ich auch gut finde
sie hat ist in nordrhein westfalen
gewesen das waren zwei sehr
unterschiedliche besucher hat sich von
unserem ministerpräsidenten einladen
lassen hat auch erklärt dass sie ihn für
führungsstark hält und so daraus kann
man etwas interpretieren aber ich will
das auch nicht über brad
überinterpretieren also angela merkel
und ich wir haben heute ein gutes
auskommen miteinander wir reden
miteinander das werden komisch mit der
geschichte wenn sie sie unterstützen
würde ausgerechnet sie wenn man jetzt
die wahl hat zwischen herr laschet
möglicherweise herrn söder android geben
da wäre seltsam basiert sich intern für
sie aussprechen würde
haben sie das gefühl sie versucht sie zu
verhindern das gefühl habe ich bisher
nicht und ich glaube ich werde es auch
in den nächsten zehn wochen nicht haben
müssen
welchen einfluss hat sie überhaupt noch
auf das ganze rennen
sie sagt ja dass sie sich heraushält das
hat sie ja auch vor zwei jahren
schon getan sie hatte ihre präferenz ja
aber sie hat sich trotzdem sehr
zurückgehalten in dieser
auseinandersetzung das war vor zwei
jahren richtig und das ist 2020 auch
richtig was haben sie gedacht in dieser
woche als sie gehört haben dass armin
laschet von karl dem großen abstand
ich habe mich darüber gefreut dass man
ministerpräsident offensichtlich einer
der ältesten herrscher familien der welt
angehört schauen wir können sie eine
ähnlichkeit auf den ersten blick sind ja
noch ein paar generationen das mandala
also ich würde dem armin laschet sagen
er soll sich mal ein bart wachsen lassen
und dann würde ich das nochmal anschauen
lacht lacht man dann sofort darüber
denkt man das ist dann ja gut da haben
sie auch alle freude daran gehabt und
ich aber es ist eine nette geschichte
kleiner cut und zu einem der wichtigsten
politischen themen in diesen zeiten der
streit um flüchtlingsaufnahme weitere
flüchtlingsaufnahme aus dem ja manchen
sagen horror lager in moria sie haben
vergangene woche kritisiert dass es dort
zusammen überbietungswettbewerb gekommen
ist auch innerhalb der großen koalition
den meinten sie eigentlich mit ihrer
kritik bei diesem kritik wort überbieten
wir haben ja mindestens drei zahlen
gehört die erste war 1000 die zweite war
4000 die dritte war 12.000 und dann hat
noch jemand gesagt alle so und da habe
ich gesagt das macht nun überhaupt
keinen sinn dass wir einfach jesu
übergegriffen die zahlen sprechen es
gibt eine regel die lautet flüchtlinge
werden in dem land aufgenommen und in
die verfahren genommen indem sie zuerst
in europa ankommen und das ist bei
diesen flüchtlingen ja nun eindeutig
griechenland ich habe auch schon vor
einiger zeit die die zustände in diesem
lager kritisiert das war
menschenunwürdig
das geht nicht so etwas das kann europa
nicht akzeptieren
aber die griechen haben niemanden
gebeten flüchtlinge aufzunehmen
das ist jetzt in deutschland trotzdem
gesagt sie sind bereit von denen die
anerkannt sind als flüchtlinge oder als
asylbewerber und diejenigen die auf dem
festland schon sind familien mit kindern
die auch hilfe und vielleicht sogar
ärztliche hilfe brauchen aufzunehmen und
das habe ich gesagt das ist völlig in
ordnung aber ansonsten ist das was die
bundesregierung jetzt beschlossen hat
und was auch in europa offensichtlich
konsens ist richtig
überbietungswettbewerb hatten sie ja
gesagt da war der stand vergangene woche
freitag noch 150 das war die erste
ankündigung von bundesinnenminister
horst seehofer dann saßen wir am
sonntagabend zusammen mit markus söder
in dieser sendung und herr söder
kündigte an es werden substanziell mehr
flüchtlinge von deutschland aufgenommen
und ein paar stunden später waren wir
dann dabei 1500 ist das auch schon
überbietungswettbewerb gewesen auch von
markus söder die bundesregierung hat
eine abwägung getroffen wie sie auch
menschen helfen kann die nun wirklich
schnell und dringend hilfe brauchen
und das ist eine völlig andere lage als
2015 in diesen lagern die die griechen
darauf den inseln haben werden die
asylverfahren durchgeführt
und wenn ich die zahl richtig
interpretiere und gelesen habe dann sind
mittlerweile 40 prozent der
lagerinsassen der menschen die dort
zurzeit untergebracht sind bereits
abgelehnte asylbewerber
das heißt diese 40 prozent wenn die zahl
richtig ist sind ohnehin nicht
berechtigt diese lager in richtung
europa oder gar in richtung deutschland
zu verlassen und die griechen machen das
was in den dublin verordnungen steht sie
prüfen die asylverfahren dort und da
gehören sie haben gerade mal schon die
menschenunwürdigen zustände in diesem
lager in moria angesprochen dieses lager
ist wie wir alle wissen zu großen teilen
abgebrannt jetzt gibt es ein neues lager
moria 2 und da wollen wir uns einmal
anschauen mit meiner kollegin jasmin
yavuz die dort ist seit über einer woche
wie es in diesem lager in moria 2
aussieht jasmin du warst einer der
wenigen journalisten journalistinnen die
in dieses lager bereits rein konnten du
warst gestern zum ersten mal dort was
hast du gesehen was hast du gefühlt und
gerochen in diesem neuen lager moria 2
hallo kann also wie du gerade schon
erwähnt hast wir waren eine der wenigen
journalisten gestern als erstes rein
durften das war allerdings noch nicht
wir können nicht gerade noch nicht hören
wir können uns der weiner park bilder
können wir können uns derweil ein paar
bilder anschauen wie du uns gestern
mitgebracht hast und sobald wir dich
hören freuen wir dich noch mal freuen
wir uns nochmal über deine einschätzung
aber wir sehen hier ein paar bilder aus
diesem lager moria 2 also das sind jetzt
flüchtlinge die dort angekommen sind und
jetzt hören wir auch sich jasmin und
beschreiben uns ein bisschen was du da
gestern gesehen hast du gerade eines der
wenigen klicks gewesen die das glück
hatten einmal ins neue lag schauen zu
dürfen und das allerdings nur unter sehr
strengen auflagen und damit meine ich
jetzt nicht oder auflagen sondern uns wo
der regel recht verboten mit den
migranten und den geflüchteten fast
sagen zu sprechen
außerdem durften die ganze nacht
hauptlager rein sondern gerade unter
quarantäne stehen wir sind natürlich
aber trotzdem mit den mit vielen
familien und menschen die in diesem
hauptlager sind immer wieder in kontakt
bekommen jeden tag updates videos fotos
die eben die situation
bilder von verdreckten toiletten
geschickt so verdreckt dass dort niemals
seine notdurft habe ich vielleicht
außerdem wurde uns gesagt dass es nur
einmal am tag etwas zu essen gebe die
wasserversorgung sei auch sehr schlecht
und den menschen dort vor ort geht es
einfach tatsächlich überhaupt nicht das
einzige was linienzug möchten danke
jasmin das also diese eindrücke aus dem
neuen lager aus moriya zwei jetzt ist
ein bisschen schwer zu verstehen wenn
wir doch alle dafür sind dass wir gerade
dort wo die flüchtlinge dann ankommen an
den außengrenzen europas menschenwürdige
zustände schaffen warum schaffen wir das
nicht wir haben die zelte dort gesehen
warum schaffen es nicht mal der
ordentliche zelte hinzustellen
er weise das kann ich von hier aus nicht
beurteilen ich habe eine einladung des
griechischen ministerpräsidenten nach
griechenland im frühjahr bekommen die
konnte ich leider bisher nicht
wahrnehmen wegen der groner beschränkung
nicht will dass versuchen so schnell wie
möglich nachzuholen da würde ich mir ein
eigenes bild machen aber die
verpflichtung liegt bei der griechischen
regierung die griechische regierung hat
die pflicht diese menschen dort
menschenwürdig unterzubringen und ich
habe ja in der letzten woche auch gesagt
wir könnten ihr aus deutschland dabei
auch helfen wir tun ist ja auch mit geld
wir könnten es mit dem deutschen roten
kreuz wir könnten es mit dem technischen
hilfswerk machen
wichtig ist dass dort menschenwürdige
zustände wie man in wahrheit so was will
man in griechenland so was vielleicht um
abzuschrecken will man ein solches
horner nein ich habe nicht den eindruck
dass der wille der griechischen
regierung ist solche zustände einfach
bewusst herbei zu führen um
entsprechende bilder auch die
öffentlichkeit zu gehen
aber es ist natürlich trotzdem klar es
gibt für diese flüchtlinge ganz
überwiegend keine perspektive auf dauer
in europa zu bleiben und das ist so hart
wie es klingt das muss man sagen
und das muss man auch aus der deutschen
sicht sagen im übrigen ich bedauere das
feststellen zu müssen aber es gibt eben
leider bis heute keinen europäischen
vorteil mechanismus außer zwei ländern
nämlich deutschland und luxemburg ist in
europa zurzeit niemand bereit weitere
flüchtlinge aufzunehmen
das ist ein europäisches problem aber
das können wir in deutschland nicht
alleine lösen
das heißt wir sind ja eigentlich genau
wieder da wo wir 2015 standen
mit einer vorreiterrolle so zu sagen
wenn man es ganz positiv ausdrückt oder
beziehungsweise isoliert in europa das
wir nämlich die einzigen sind die dazu
bereit sind in größeren mengen
flüchtlinge dort aus diesem lager
aufzunehmen nein das sehe ich nicht so
er weise wir sind in einer anderen
situation als 2015 2015 gab es eine
umfangreiche illegale einwanderung über
die balkanroute nach ungarn nach
österreich und anschließend nach
deutschland
jetzt reden wir über die aufnahme von
anerkannten flüchtlingen und
asylbewerbern und besonderen härtefällen
etwa wenn kinder betroffen sind
das ist eine völlig andere situation als
und deswegen haben diejenigen die auch
in berlin in der letzten woche auch
bundestagsabgeordnete gesagt haben das
darf sich nicht wiederholen völlig recht
ist wiederholt sich auch nicht ich bin
ich noch ganz kurz ein mann vorstellen
der in münchen wohnt seit vielen jahren
das ist nicht markus söder sondern als
mir kreis der nämlich aus syrien nach
deutschland gekommen ist und jetzt auf
sein bruder wartet dem wir in diesen
tagen in lesbos dort auf lesbos in dem
flüchtlingslager auch gesehen und
besucht haben herr kaiser erstmal
schönen guten abend nach münchen wenn
wir über dieses thema streiten lesbos
wie für flüchtlinge können wir aufnehmen
und sie vor allen dingen ihren bruder
und dessen familie im kopf haben wie
sehr wie sehr bangen sie um ihn und wie
sehr hoffen sie möglicherweise
berechtigt dass auch er nach deutschland
kommt ja hallo haben und nicht ich höre
sie wunderbar hks jungen arbeiten und
ich bedanke mich also ab diese auf
meiner lage für zusagen und meinem
bruder vielleicht haben die die video
gesehen und die bilder zu buchen ist
mein bruder mit meiner drei kinder und
mit einer kräuterfrau also ich bin hier
seit lange hier in deutschland ich bin
ich bin jetzt momentan hilflos ich kann
ihm nicht helfen weil ich habe damals
vor vier jahren als kleine brote gehüllt
und hab ja und ich habe ihm
unterstützung da ich habe eine strafe
bekommen sechs monate im mädchenhaft
mussten und 60.000 euro durch strafe
zahlen müssen
und da will ich momentan hand abgebildet
ist kann nicht mehr ihnen nicht helfen
aber ich habe keine andere möglichkeit
nur an einen die euch und die politiker
dass euch bitten meinem bruder also ich
habe die zwei gründer von dieser laden
irgendwie schlimmste ragen heraus zu
holen und freue mich sehr als wenn ich
das hier in deutschland ihm im arm zu
nehmen weil das ist wie sind hier also
großer familie da ich würde meine bruder
noch sechs schwester und die hälfte die
familie sind griechenland also momentan
befindet sich er sehr in schieflage
sozusagen und in den wald fall das hat
seiner frau auch die fußball gewarnt wir
waren die bilder für euch an scheinbar
auf euch alles gesehen und er hat auch
ein kind dort auch an hat ein kind
bekommen ein kind von ihm es in moria
zur welt gekommen wie sie uns in der
welt bekommen sie uns erzählt haben
lassen sie uns diese frage verteilen wir
lassen sie uns diese frage einmal kurz
mit herrn merz diskutieren weil dahinter
natürlich immer diese familienschicksale
stehen jetzt ist es ganz schwierig
deutschland hat ein kreis aufgenommen
dahinter steht eine größere familie die
aus syrien gekommen ist die jetzt in
moria fest sitzt seit über einem jahr
dort wie gesagt ein kind geboren hat wie
gehen sie wie würden sie mit solchen
fällen umgehen kann man den leuten sagen
ihr müsst in griechenland bleiben wie
kann man dazu kommen dass sie
möglicherweise doch nach deutschland
kommen oder nicht man ist hin und her
lassen wie entscheiden sie ist also
diese persönlichen schicksale
insbesondere wenn kinder betroffen sind
berühren jeden müssen jeden berühren der
selber auch kinder hat und trotzdem ist
es ja die aufgabe auch von staatlichen
institutionen von regierungen von
behörden nicht auf den einzelfall und
auf das einzelne schicksal zu schauen
sondern eine allgemein geltende regeln
aufzustellen und ich kenne den
aufenthaltsstatus von der ja nicht ich
weiß auch nicht in welchem status sein
bruder sich befindet aber ich sag mal
natürlich ist familienzusammenführung
eine schöne sache aber wir müssen hier
in deutschland wir müssen hier in europa
regeln haben die für alle gelten
und ich hab dann gerade noch gesagt
sechs schwestern stehen auch noch an das
geht einfach nicht dass wir da jetzt nur
auf dieses einzelschicksal oder dieser
einzelne familie schauen wir müssen
allgemeine regel maloja hinaus weil das
eine so schwierige aber saß frage
natürlich ist herzlichen dank herr kreis
wir wollten das einmal an diesem fall an
ihrem fall diskutieren und werden weiter
mit ihnen in kontakt bleiben um die
mitte währung um herauszufinden wie es
bei ihnen weitergeht und meine kollegin
jasmin jahres wird auch mit ihrem bruder
weiterhin kontakt bleiben herzlichen
dank dass sie heute abend bei uns waren
real sendung noch mal auf diese
isolation im moment in europa zu
sprechen zu kommen die deutschland dort
hat in dieser frage wie viele und ob
überhaupt man flüchtlinge aus moriya
aufnimmt unterstützen sie eigentlich
diesen weg österreich macht das ganz
anders sie haben ganz oft sebastian kurz
auch für seinen weg gelobt das heißt
stehen sie jetzt im moment an merkels
und seehofers seite oder teilen sie
möglicherweise auch ein großes stück der
kritik von sebastian kurz naja ich habe
ja auch in dieser sendung schon gesagt
ich finde diese entscheidung geht aus
humanitären gründen eine kleine gruppe
von menschen aufzunehmen die besonders
hilfsbedürftig ist richtig und trotzdem
halte ich es unverändert für notwendig
dass wir eine einheitliche europäische
regeln haben wir haben regeln die gelten
die griechen halten sich an diese regeln
wir haben kein vorteil mechanismus das
ist ein großes problem version langreder
zehn jahren aber er weiß ich muss es
einfach deswegen noch einmal sagen und
deswegen halte ich auch eine strikte
begrenzung des zuzugs nach deutschland
für richtig und ich beteilige mich auch
nicht an diesem von ihnen eben schon
einmal zitierten überbietungswettbewerb
ich halte das für falsch das gibt
hoffnungen die nicht real sind und vor
allen dingen das löst kein wirkliches
problem wir müssen dieses problem mit
den flüchtlingen anders lösen als mit
einer deutschen vorreiterrolle oder gar
mit einer deutschen allein heute genauso
in deutschland alleingang machen sie
nicht mit weiters ist meine meinung
verstehen die leute die jetzt sagen
gerade wenn man diese schicksale wie das
von herrn k s sie sagen es da sind noch
ganz viele schwer es dann noch ganz
viele brüder dass die jetzt einmal sagen
leute wir haben wir sind ganz großzügig
aber jetzt sind wirklich einfach die
anderen dran
ja und wissen sie ich war etwas
überrascht als ich das zugestimmt habe
sagte aber dass das für richtig halte
mit diesen 1500 was da teilweise auch in
den social media kanälen und was da
teilweise auch in den chatrooms von
zeitungen und rundfunk und
fernsehanstalten lief da bin ich dafür
kritisiert worden dass ich überhaupt
dieses zugeständnis in anführungsstriche
mit den 1500 gemacht habe die stimmung
in der bevölkerung ist klar und
eindeutig die große mehrheit der
deutschen will nicht mehr zuzug so und
ich bin mit dieser meinung dass wir das
im augenblick nicht leisten können und
wir brauchen da gemeinsame analysen
gemeinsame europäische regeln wissend
dass wir sie im augenblick ob der lage
nicht bekommen wundern sie sich dann
manchmal über markus zu wieder zwei
jahre ist es her dass er asyl tourismus
kritisiert hat dieses wort hat er damals
im wahlkampf zu beginn des wahlkampfs
geprägt asyl tourismus kritisiert hat
und jetzt schlägt er vor die zahl
vergangene woche hier die zahl der
moorea flüchtlinge die nach deutschland
kommen sollen substanziell zu erhöhen
wundern sich über nein er hat ja etwas
benannt was es damals vielleicht in
dieser form gab das hat das ist längst
erledigt wir hatten ja auch in schweden
hat sich das wäre richtig er hat jetzt
hat das auf einzelfälle bezogen wollte
das ausdrücklich nicht generalisieren
und er hatte in der letzten woche nach
dem von 100 die rede war gesagt es
könnten auch mehr werden es sind dann
mehr geworden aber noch einmal sie haben
also haben das aber ganz anders als 2015
ganz anders es sind anerkannte
flüchtlinge oder asylbewerber von denen
wir jetzt eine kleine gruppe nach
deutschland aus humanitären gründen
nehmen und das ist aus meiner sicht in
ordnung
mehr geht nicht sie haben gerade über
die von ihnen wahrgenommenen stimmung
unter allen deutschen erfolg gesprochen
wir wissen das ganz ganz viele die
merkelsche flüchtlingspolitik kritisiert
hat dass ich auch eine partei ja nicht
gegründet hat deswegen aber umso mehr
zulauf gewonnen hat ist es ihr ziel
diese kritiker der flüchtlingspolitik
wieder zur cdu zurückzuholen mehr wissen
sie ich habe die bundestagswahl 2017 in
erinnerung und wir hatten bei der
bundestagswahl 2017 so etwa drei wochen
vorher in den umfragen diese partei
irgendwo um die fünf bis sieben prozent
und dann gab es zehn tage vor der wahl
die große fernsehsendung der
spitzenkandidaten und über die hälfte
dieser fernsehsendung drehte sich nur um
das thema flüchtlinge und innerhalb von
einer woche innerhalb von zwei tagen war
das an allen ständen draußen wieder das
hauptthema so und das dafür 2021 nicht
das hauptthema wieder werden es ist das
hier diese leute zurück zur cdu zu holen
für die die cdu wieder wählbar ein ziel
ist es so viel wie möglich von denen die
wir verloren haben natürlich an die afd
deren zahl wird jetzt immer kleiner weil
diese partei sich komplett ins abseits
dreht aber auch diejenigen die wir in
die nicht wählerschaft verloren haben
das sind viele
und diejenigen die wir möglicherweise
auch an die grünen verloren haben oder
noch verlieren an die cdu zurück zwar
konkret wir werden wir alle kennen
möglicherweise im erweiterten
bekanntenkreis sogar zumindest kennen
wir sie
kennen sie sie aus ihrer eigenen partei
ausgetreten wer also ganz konkret die
die wegen merkels merkels
flüchtlingspolitik ausgedreht wollen sie
für die die cdu wieder welcher weise ich
kann das doch nicht ab und sage jetzt
ist merkel vorbei und jetzt könnte er
zurückkommt das ist ja nicht neu es geht
mir um das thema flüchtlingspolitik dass
man da eben sie haben ja gerade sich
leicht abgesetzt von dem aktuellen kurs
der groko das heißt das könnte ein
schritt in die richtung seiner und sich
leute wieder die tür auch so dass
diejenigen die in der wirtschafts und
finanzpolitik diejenigen die die
arbeitsmarktpolitik in der umweltpolitik
in der energiepolitik der meinung sind
das muss an der einen oder anderen
stelle vielleicht etwas konsistenter
werden zurückgewinnen die mit der lage
im augenblick unzufrieden sind
wir haben im augenblick eine relativ
stabile demoskopie die union steht
zurzeit bei 38 prozent aber ich bin
realistisch genug das ist im augenblick
und den umständen geschuldet das hat
etwas mit angela merkel und dem großen
vertrauen der bevölkerung in ihre
führung zu tun aber das ist nicht die
basis auf der wir aufbauen können für
das wahljahr 221 wir werden bei der
bundestagswahl 20 21 praktisch von vorn
beginnen müssen und wir werden etwas
sagen müssen für die zukunft und wir
werden nicht gewählt aus dankbarkeit für
die vergangenheit für das management in
der korona krise gibt es wie sie es
schon gesagt haben überwiegend
zustimmung im moment manche sagen noch
es weg wachsen aber auch die zweifel an
der sinnhaftigkeit viele regeln es
wächst der protest auf den straßen in
berlin wir alle erinnern die bilder
waren es rund 40.000 die dort auf der
straße waren
halten sie es geht ja viel in dieser
frage und vernunft und unvernunft halten
sie die corinna regeln über alles
eigentlich für vernünftig halte sich
über alles für vernünftig und habe
trotzdem zweifel an der einen oder
anderen einzel entscheidung
mir macht vor allem große sorgen der
zustand der schulen und dass die kinder
nicht uneingeschränkt in die schulen
gehen können ich erlebe das in der
eigenen familie wie eingeschränkt dass
dort ist und diese wochen die die kinder
in den schulen verlieren sind ganz
schwer nachzuholen und insbesondere die
aus sozial schwachen familien aber ist
er jetzt wieder hört man es ja gar nicht
nur einschränkung durch den mundschutz
oder die absenkung weil sofort die
lehrer fehlen wenn sie ein schnupfen
haben oder ja was meinte da habe ich zum
beispiel große sympathie für karin prien
in schleswig holstein die da sehr
rigoros sagt also diejenigen die nicht
wirklich ganz
ernsthaft erkrankt sind unter den
lehrern müssen kommen und akzeptiert da
keine einfachen ärztlichen atteste das
finde ich richtig wir brauchen dieses
system schule das muss funktionieren und
zwar auch in kona zeugen also es bleiben
noch zu viele lehrer mit visa ist
bleiben einfach zu viele zuhause
gewöhnen sich ohnehin im augenblick
relativ viele menschen daran
ein leben ohne arbeit zu führen das ist
in der krise richtig nur ich habe diese
woche in einem hotel übernachtet wo
praktisch überhaupt kein personal mehr
vorhanden war
also wir müssen ein bisschen aufpassen
dass wir uns nicht alle daran gewöhnen
dass wir ohne arbeit leben können wir
müssen zurück an die arbeit und wir
müssen auch in unserem privatleben
möglichst viele freiheiten wieder haben
also ich stehe immer auf der seite die
sagen so wenig einschränkungen wie
möglich und nötig aber bitte auch so
viele freiheiten für die menschen
draußen wie eben möglich und zwar im
beruf wie im privaten ist das ein
langzeit schaden möglicherweise von
corona dass so viele deutsche nicht mehr
gewünschte zur arbeit also wir werden
wahrscheinlich erst im abstand von
einigen jahren genau analysieren können
was jetzt passiert ich mache kein
geheimnis daraus dass ich skeptisch bin
ob diese sehr lange verlängerung des
kurzarbeitergeld bis ende 20 21 die
richtige lösung ist das ist jetzt
entschieden aber den arbeitsmarkt
beobachten müssen
meine befürchtung ist wir bekommen die
mitarbeiter dort wo wir sie brauchen wo
wir sie dringend brauchen nicht weil sie
fest gebunden sind an die firmen von
denen die kurzarbeitergeld oder für die
sie kurzarbeitergeld bekommen schauen
was uns an im laufe der nächsten wochen
und monate die lage verhält hat schön
noch zur wahl das kurzarbeitergeld
ja ich habe mir auch so zwischendurch
mal die frage gestellt hätte die
koalition das eigentlich auch gemacht
wenn wir im herbst 2021 keine
bundestagswahl gehabt hätte und private
vor
wahrscheinlich hätte man das
quartalsweise nach vorne geschrieben und
nicht jetzt mal hat das nicht ja es ist
eine spekulation
man hat es nicht gemacht das sagen sie
so klingt das bei ihm durch wollte auf 1
noch durch darauf hinaus auf die
vernunft die ja immer den zugeschrieben
wird die konsequent die regeln einhalten
und jetzt sagen sie aber auch bei
manchen regeln zweifeln sie durchaus an
bei manchen
die vernünftig sind können sie mir
erklären wir haben gerade über die
schulen schon gesprochen warum man in
schulen teilweise oder in vielen schulen
sogar auf dem schulhof mundschutz tragen
muss und dem theater aber nur weiß nicht
100 leute sitzen dürfen wenn überhaupt
bald auseinander sondern können sie die
fußballstadien noch gleich mit dazu
nehmen andere sportstätten mitnehmen
sind sie und die ganze veranstaltung
können sie auch nicht erklären
nein ich kann es kaum noch erklären also
mir fehlt da auch die konsistenz
nun muss man vielleicht zur erklärung
zumindest zur erklärung vielleicht auch
zur entschuldung sagen es ist ja auch
ein prozess von versuch und irrtum so
was hat man ja bei uns ein war fair und
wirklich auch auch zu denen die jetzt
die verantwortung trage total für das
ist eine verdammt schwierige frage für
alle betrifft es gibt ein paar dinge die
so dem normalen alltag einfach
widersprechen wenn man sechs siegen auf
dem schulhof vorschreiben möchte den
mundschutz errang
ein anderes foto vom wochenende sie
haben gerade die stadien schon
angesprochen
können sie erklären warum man in der
loge beim fc bayern münchen eng
beieinander sitzt aber stattdessen ganz
streng in der fankurve die regeln
einhält
nein absolut nicht
und ich muss sagen als ich das bild
gesehen aber erst freunde was ist denn
mit euch los nein ich kann es nicht
erklären
der deutsche fußball-bund hat regeln und
die damen und herren halten sich nicht
an dieser west übermut oder ist das so
eine wir sind wir sehen das ja auch auf
von vielen oder von manchen politikern
in anderen ländern also äußern sich
tagsüber zu den chor ohne regeln und
gehen abends im privaten mit vielen
leuten feiern
all diese fälle gab es schon geht dann
manchmal jahr für für mich muss das
nicht gehalten oder ich krieg hat das
ist nicht das ist jetzt überhaupt
mitglied bei borussia dortmund wird das
hat damit gar nichts zu tun ich würde
sagen wenn es völlig anders wäre aber
was ich da gesehen habe spontan meine
mein gedanke dummheit oder arroganz ein
letztes beispiel ich wollte ja auf diese
unfall nun floh der vernunft noch einmal
hinaus ein letztes beispiel in kirchen
darf nicht gesungen werden aber
prostitution es erlaubt haben sie eine
große schlagzeile draus gemacht aus
diesem thema ich hätte mir auch anders
vorstellen können jetzt ist ja noch zeit
also man kann ja jetzt reagieren und die
kirchen wieder öffnen bzw
das singen dort wieder erlauben könnte
für die reise sei eine möglichkeit sein
das krippenspiel dann doch nicht digital
habt ja also ich würde mir jedenfalls
wünschen gerade für die advents und
weihnachtszeit dass wir wieder etwas
mehr möglichkeiten hätten die kirchen zu
besuchen und das vor allen dingen solche
solche inkonsistenten sind oder solche
widersprüche da nicht ständig
wiederholen das nicht wir waren gerade
schon kurz bei den wirtschaftlichen
folgen der korona krise und sind da auch
schon fast ein bisschen tiefer
eingestiegen das können wir jetzt noch
mal tun
wie würden sie als parteichef als
kanzler deutschland aus der tiefsten
rezession wieder herausführen
wir müssen sorgfältig analysieren wo
unsere schwachstellen sind wir hatten ja
auch schon einige erhebliche schwächen
vor corinna das ist ja nicht alles
corona was wir im augenblick sehen
sondern von corinna wird vieles
beschleunigt was schon vorher da war ich
sehe das größte defizit bei uns im
augenblick und das ist ja schon fast
trivial und wird ja langsam müde ist
auch ständig zu wiederholen aber es ist
leider so
das größte defizit unserer wirtschaft
ist die mangelnde digitalisierung wir
haben stärken gesehen wir haben
dramatische schwächen gesehen
die fehlende digitalisierung der schulen
ist eine dramatische schwäche dieses
landes die mangelnde übertragungsraten
die man in der abdeckung auch im ganzen
land gerade in den ländlichen räumen
das ist etwas was wir ganz schnell jetzt
nachholen müssen
ich will einen zweiten punkt sagen mir
macht große sorge dass wir zu wenig
junge unternehmen haben
es gibt viele die unternehmen hier
gründen aber es gibt davon viel zu viele
die dann auch anschließend aufgekauft
werden abwandern nach china gehen nach
amerika gehen
nehmen sie mal so ein beispiel wie
kuwait dieses unternehmen in tübingen
ist jetzt in new york an die börse
gegangen warum gehen die in new york an
die börse und nicht in europa ist london
nicht gut genug paris nicht gut genug
frankfurt nicht gut genug was ist da los
also wir brauchen im grunde genommen
über die gesamte wertschöpfungskette
unserer volkswirtschaft wirklich echte
anstrengungen und da muss meines
erachtens mehr passieren und das ganze
muss sauber verpackt werden
auch in die umweltpolitik aber das muss
eine in sich schlüssige konsistente
politik sein
politik die gibt es derzeit nicht wollte
gerade sagen ihre partei regiert ja nun
schon sehr lange sie haben auch das
wirtschaftsministerium mit herrn
altmaier
jetzt gibt es heute vielleicht haben sie
erstmal twitter verfolgt eine ganz
lebendige debatte zwischen peter
altmaier und christian lindner geht auf
dem parteitag der fdp zurück wo es einen
scharfen angriff von lindner gegenüber
herrn altmaier gab der ihm ja sozusagen
untätigkeit vorwirft in der
wirtschaftspolitik sind sie da so ganz
weit von herrn lindner entfernt oder
möglicherweise doch nicht
also ich definiere mich jetzt nicht aus
meiner nähe oder meinem abstand zu
christian lindner sondern ich sage
einfach wir haben zwei sehr über diesen
kleinen wo der kurs streiten heute
weiter ging ja gut also der peter
altmaier macht zurzeit sehr viel macht
in der krisenbewältigung gibt ein gutes
bild ab ich vermisse in der stringenz
der bundesregierung insgesamt ein
bisschen perspektive für die
wirtschaftspolitik in den nächsten
jahren ich habe das thema angesprochen
digitalisierung da wird jetzt manches
nachgeholt ich finde die geschwindigkeit
ist nicht ausreichend
wir müssen in der ganzen frage junge
start-ups junger unternehmen besser
werden wir müssen gerade für diese junge
generation die sich selbständig machen
will bessere perspektiven schaffen wir
müssen irgendwann mal auch mit diesem
geld ausgeben aufhören also ich finde
was scholz da macht ist grenzwertig eine
bremse zu lösen die schuldenbremse zu
lösen so wie es im grundgesetz steht ist
richtig aber deswegen muss man nicht mit
vollgas den berg runterfahren
also da wird geld raus gehauen in einem
umfang was ich ehrlich gesagt in dieser
form nicht mehr nachvollziehen kann und
die nächste generation muss das alles
bezahlen also da wünschte ich mir ein
bisschen mehr perspektive über den
reinen krisen tag hinaus fällt natürlich
leichter den spd-finanzminister zu
kritisieren aber die kritik von herrn
linden erzielte ja schon ins schwarze
gegenüber herrn altmaier
er wirft ihm staatswirtschaft vor gehen
sie damit finden sie das auch zu viel
gerade die ganzen unternehmen zu
finanzieren die möglicherweise gar nicht
mehr durchgehalten hätte ich hätte mir
jedenfalls ohne dass ich das jetzt als
kritik am peter altmeier verstanden
wissen will vorstellen können dass man
die staatshilfen für die unternehmen die
sie brauchen und die lufthansa braucht
sie anders macht
in form von unternehmensbeteiligungen
das hätte man auch durch andere form
machen können da gibt es viele
möglichkeiten nachrangige darlehen da
kann man reingehen als stiller
gesellschafter da kann man reingehen als
stimmrechtsloser vorzugsaktion er also
die die spd denkt immer sehr stark in
staatskapitalistischen kategorien und
die cdu ist ihr da wie ich finde ein
bisschen zuviel gefolgt da hätte ich mir
zumindest mal gewünscht dass es auch
über alternativen diskussionen gegeben
hätte und dass auch aus dem
bundeswirtschaftsministerium vielleicht
die eine oder andere alternative als
vorschlag gekommen wäre ja lassen sie
uns über ein großes wirtschaftsprojekt
sprechen nord stream 2 umso mehr in der
kritik natürlich nach der vergiftung
navalny stil dessen spuren und eindeutig
nach russland und dort in die regierung
führt nun gibt es in ihrer partei
wichtige stimmen die trotzdem sagen wir
dürfen das projekt auf keinen fall
beenden ich fliege sogar auf jeden fall
im dezember nach moskau und treffe mich
mit putin sagt sachsens
ministerpräsident kretschmann
was antworten sie ich schätze michael
kretschmer persönlich sehr
ich bin in dieser frage anderer meinung
wobei es im prinzip immer richtig ist
dass wir miteinander reden
die frage ist nur was sagen wir da und
was tun wir da und nachdem nun dieser
erneute giftanschlag offensichtlich auf
russische quellen zurückzuführen ist
russland sich jedenfalls an der
aufklärung überhaupt nicht beteiligt wir
aber sehr starke hinweise darauf haben
dass ohne beteiligung großer stellen
solche giftgas anschläge giftanschläge
gar nicht möglich wären
muss ich sagen ist der punkt gekommen wo
man jetzt doch mal die frage stellen
muss auch wir alles so weitermachen
können wie bisher die frage hinter 72
eine komplexe geschichte zur zeit müssen
die dänen darüber entscheiden ob weiter
gebaut wird oder nicht was durch
dänisches hoheitsgewässer geht im grunde
genommen das ist aber auch jetzt
zu spät darüber noch einmal nachzugehen
lassen jetzt die sekunde vertiefen wir
gleich aber lassen die sekunde bei herrn
kretschmer bleiben besuch jetzt in
moskau ankündigen und zu sagen man dürfe
jetzt die eskalation nicht weitertreiben
die eskalation die ja bedeutete herne
war nie zu vergiften
wie stehen sie das also von deutschland
und von europa geht keine eskalation aus
sollten sie herrn putin jetzt bist du
diese eskalation geht zurzeit
ausschließlich von russland aus und ob
ich einen besuch machen würde oder nicht
darüber müsste ich nachdenken
jedenfalls geht es jetzt nicht
unkritisch einfach so weiter wie bisher
ich habe den vorschlag gemacht ein
zweijähriges moratorium über diese
pipeline und dann vernünftig reden und
versuchen wieder eine lösung zu finden
aber das setzt voraus dass wir uns auf
der europäischen seite einig sind wir
sind uns leider ja noch nicht einmal in
deutschland einig ist dass besonders
konsequenten moratorium zu fordern oder
ist das so ein bisschen kompromiss weil
man sich nicht recht entscheiden kann
zwischen dem einen und dem anderen mal
zwei jahre einzufrieren und dann weiter
zu bauen
wir wissen teilweise die politik besteht
häufig aus kompromissen und es geht auch
hier mal so wie der einzelne sich tasten
und gerne wünscht es gibt viele die
sagen abbrechen
also nehmen sie die grünen die alle der
meinung sind sofort abbrechen
es gibt viele die sagen das geht auch
aus juristischen gründen überhaupt nicht
wir müssen sie in jedem fall auch aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen weiterbauen
ich glaube aus wirtschaftlichen grund
brauchen wir sie im augenblick nicht die
gasversorgung europas ist gesichert wir
brauchen nicht diese zweite pipeline
durch die ostsee
aber wir werden sie irgendwann
wahrscheinlich zu ende bauen wollen
vielleicht auch müssen aber so ganz
einfach zur tagesordnung überzugehen
finde ich geht auch nicht und deswegen
habe ich diesen vorschlag im atlantik
konkreter machen nicht einfach zur
tagesordnung übergehen also was müsste
dann in dieser zeit in denen in der zeit
von wie sie sagen zwei jahren passieren
um dann doch weiter zu bauen um das
projekt zu vollenden was einmal wissen
was ich jetzt roland müsste mit putin
mal ganz grundsätzlich die frage
diskutieren wie verhält er sich
eigentlich auf der internationalen bühne
und da stehen ja eine ganze reihe von
konflikten auch in rhede da reden wir
und die ost ukraine
da reden wir natürlich auch über syrien
ich meine dieser mann und seine armee
bombardieren krankenhäuser kindergärten
schulen altenheime mit einer der
wesentlichen fluchtursachen die probleme
die wir da jetzt ein griechenland haben
sind probleme die ganz wesentlich mit
ausgelöst worden sind durch diese
barbarischen krieg sagte der russischen
armee die putin zu verantworten hat
sowie putin muss zurück an den
verhandlungstisch wir müssen formate
finden wie man mit ihm vernünftige
gespräche führt welche formate dazu
geeignet sind muss die politik
diskutieren ob wir vielleicht die alte
ksc die osze wiederbeleben ob wir andere
formate finden nur so wie er sich hier
verhält kann der westen das nicht
unbeantwortet lassen also das wäre eine
klare bedingung um in dieser moratoriums
zeit dann wieder zum leiter bei yoox 1
zugunsten zurück an den
verhandlungstisch und sagte die zeit zu
nutzen von formate zu entwickeln wie wir
auch als europäer mit ihm sprechen
und dazu bedarf es einer engen und guten
europäischen abstimmung ist müssen zu
mindestens zwei oder drei staaten in
europa diesen weg gemeinsam gehen und da
liegt die größte aufgabe wahrscheinlich
bei deutschland denn wir müssen mit
frankreich zusammen einen weg versuchen
zu eröffnen wir müssen es aber auch mit
polen tun
wir müssen für die gesamte europäische
union ein bisschen auch die richtung
aufzeigen in der wie in die wir da gehen
könnten ich will hier noch eine etwas
jüngere frau vorstellen die in ihrer
partei ist das ist lilli fischer die uns
jetzt zugeschaltet ist sie ist in der
cdu in thüringen und mit ihr wollen wir
ein bisschen darüber sprechen dass die
cdu ja im moment noch ein paar probleme
hat bei jungen menschen und vor allen
dingen bei jungen wählerinnen warum ist
das eigentlich so nach so vielen jahren
einer weiblichen kanzlerschaft lili
fischer
ich glaube dass das problem einerseits
schon mal dort liegt zu sagen weil wir
nicht kanzlerin haben weil wir es ein
kommissionspräsidentin haben und einen
verteidigungsministerium haben zum alles
große aushängeschild auf uns als cdu
sind tolle frauen meines erachtens das
trügt häufig glaube ich auch noch auf
darüber hinweg dass sie bei uns als
partei viel zu wenig frauen haben es
liegt das problem viel tiefer die größte
wählerschaft die wir haben sind frauen
wir müssen uns also gefragt
schnell machen begeistert frauen
thematisch so dass wir uns fehlen aber
warum sollen wir frau so begeistert dass
sie bei uns eintreten und ich glaube das
nicht für mich vor allem erst einmal
daran wie fest politische strukturen
sind und wie fest bei uns auch
sitzungstermine sind ich meine auch als
nächstes bringt gerade für mich als
schülerin
wenn ich zu meinem ersten stammtisch
gekommen wäre und dort hätte keine
andere frau am tisch gesessen ich wäre
wahrscheinlich auf dem absatz umgedreht
und wieder weg gerannt war jetzt das
natürlich häufig immer noch große männer
unten sind und ich glaube dass wenn wir
es schaffen mehr frauen dafür zu
begeistern dass wir ordentliche
strukturen haben ordentliche sitzung
zeiten die nicht bis abends in die
späten nachmittages späten abend wird
reingehen
ich glaube dass das ein erster schritt
ist aber es braucht natürlich auch
frauen förderprogrammen und ich glaube
dass auf im entwurf der struktur unseres
kommission darf wichtige punkte drin
stehen aber was hätte ja auch sein
können dass in der langen kanzlerschaft
merkel
umso mehr frauen in die partei drängen
um so mehr eintreten wollen warum ist
das nicht passiert was glauben sie
frage ich kann dazu sagen ich habe mit
einem anderen jahrhundert zusammen ein
podcast er nennt sich women's planning
wo wir regelmäßig frauen zu gast haben
uns ein bisschen die welt erklären genau
das was rom ins training und ulrike
hofsähs professorin für europarecht an
der donau uni und sie hat uns erklärt
dass es quasi dieses unterschiedliche
format von frau für das gibt la mer und
lauf haben und es gibt das nicht diese
typische frauenbild ganz klassisch
eigentlich wahrscheinlich angegeben
hohen schuhen läuft es gibt quasi die
mutter und das was man wahrscheinlich
auch für angela merkel sagt dass man
immer hört ist mutti bin ich sagen dass
sie keine typische frau ist aber ich
glaube sie hat einen guten moment
abgepasst in einem männer struktur
einzutreten
ich weiß nicht ob nur eine frau an der
spitze
irgendwo frauen davon überzeugen kann
selber eins getreten
ich glaube da braucht es viel offenere
weiter gefasste themenbereiche und
arbeitssitzungen genau das was ich
gerade gesagt habe und frauen so
umfassen können das gerne dabei sein
aber das ist n tv
das ist interessant frau fischer würden
sie also sagen
frau merkel hat die cdu in der ganzen
zeit in der sie die partei geführt hat
nicht weiblicher gemacht ich glaub
tatsächlich lange nicht ich brauche also
von merkels ziemlich am anfang würde
hätte sie sich niemals als feministin
bezeichnet und je weiter ihre
kanzlerschaft vorangegangen ist desto
eher ist sie doch zu diesen blogs würde
sich immer noch nicht als feministin
bezeichnen dass ich im übrigen auch
nicht vor aber ich glaube dass immer
mehr zu diesem typ geworden der gesagt
wir brauchen wirklich mehr frauen und
wir müssen die wirklich ankurbeln
ich glaube dass die problemlage gerade
zum anfang ihrer kanzlerschaft nicht so
bewusst warum nicht so in der
gesellschaft würden sie das auch sagen
herr merz dass die äußeren die partei
nicht weiblicher gemacht hat naja ob es
an der kanzlerin liegt oder an der
parteivorsitzenden
das ist eine frage die kann man so und
so beantworten
tatsächlich haben wir zu wenig frauen in
der cdu unter frauen an land liegt
irgendwo bei 24 prozent
in der bevölkerung liegt er über 50 und
damit ist die partei schon von ihrer
zusammensetzung her nicht mehr
repräsentativ für die deutsche
bevölkerung das ist für uns ein
riesenproblem ist nun frau fischer herr
merz der richtige ihrer meinung nach um
die partei weiblicher zu machen jünger
zu machen moderner zu machen zukünftiger
zu machen wie er sagt wir haben drei
männer als kandidat
wenn sie jetzt sagen dass eine frau
schon eine partei nicht sicher machen
kann nur weil sie eine frau ist wie kann
das dann nach dieser logik ein mann tun
ich glaube tatsächlich dass es in den
neuen führungsteam egal wer unser
parteivorsitzender für eine starke frau
an der seite des parteivorsitzenden
braucht die sich ehrlich und engagiert
für frauenförderung einsätze ich glaube
dass andere kramp-karrenbauer das gerade
sehr sehr sehr gut war und ich wünsche
mir dass dieses engagement fort betragen
wird durch den jetzt parteivorsitz durch
herrn merz trauen sie hinzu letzte frage
ehrlich so sehr ich habe mir als hetze
und so sehr ich seiner expertise das
wissen wir alle
er ist tatsächlich aber wenn nicht mein
wunschkandidat auch wenn ich glaube dass
mit herrn merz cdu auf jeden fall nicht
untergehen würde
und ich glaube auch nicht dass er merkt
das schon dass maximale präsident
herbert ihnen geht die cdu nicht und das
ist aber wie werden die werben sie
werden sie um frau fischer und um viele
andere junge frauen in deutschland die
noch nicht in der cdu sind wie werben
sie um die also so die sp frau fischer
vielen dank für diese offenheit und für
die ehrlichkeit ich teile die analyse
wir müssen wirklich sehen dass wir das
jetzt bald und kontinuierlich verbessern
sie hat einen punkt angesprochen der
sicher ganz wichtig ist nämlich die art
und weise wie wir politisch arbeiten
das ist weitgehend geprägt von männern
die sich abends um ihre familien nicht
kümmern müssen
und das geht so nicht mehr wir müssen
das unter sie verändern müssten uns
nicht tun oder müssten uns nicht tun gut
nun haben wir auch gott sei dank eine
andere generation von männern die sich
mehr um ihre kinder kümmern als das
früher der fall war
trotzdem gilt für beide wir müssen auf
andere formate gehen
und der will ich mal deutlich sagen wir
wir werden unsere satzungen auch die
kommunalen ordnungen ändern müssen zum
beispiel dass auch beschlussfassungen
digital möglich sind das können wir
zurzeit noch nicht also wir müssten
eigentlich so schnell wie möglich dafür
sorgen dass parteiarbeit auch durch
videokonferenzen stattfinden kann
beschlüsse gefasst werden können auf
diesem weg und da muss sich viel ändern
ich würde mir sehr wünschen dass wir im
nächsten jahr wirklich eine
entsprechende initiative auf den weg
bringen wo dann auch im verlaufe des
bundestags war jahres und das sind ja
immer war ja mal jahre sind immer gut
geeignet für parteieintritt wenn man es
richtig macht kriegt man in einem
wahljahr dann auch wirklich neue junge
mitglieder und dafür würde ich mich sehr
stark wie würden sie sich zutrauen haben
sie eine größenordnung im national so
wäre wie sich die mitgliederentwicklung
her entwickelt hat jetzt also ich sag
mal so viel wie ich hab's ja eben schon
gesagt wir liegen jetzt bei 24 25
prozent also wir müssten das ziel haben
wenigstens auf 30 prozent zu kommen und
dann sind wir immer noch vom
durchschnitt weit entfernt schwupps da
hat sich frau verabschiedet ich will
noch ein argument bevor wir sie
verabschieden ein argument noch mit
aufnehmen sie sagt ja herr merz soll
sich dann wenigstens jemand zu der alten
eben jemand starkes haben sie schon
jemanden im kopf ich habe mehrere
personen im kopf
und ich werde das zum gegebenen
zeitpunkt auch öffentlich sagen und die
wissen auch schon gezahlt haben
ich denke sie werden ganz zufrieden also
frau fischer könnte eine kandidatin sein
falls sie doch noch nicht so ganz wieder
in ihrem kopf hatten werden sie wie noch
vor ihrer wahl zum parteivorsitzenden
oder werden sich eigentlich danke frau
fischer das historisches herzlich grüße
nach tirano schritte werden sie sich
eigentlich mit ihren gegenkandidaten vor
dem parteitag einigen wer das rennen
macht es gibt ja stimmen wie zum
beispiel frau klöckner die sagt da
sollte man sich vorher mal einigen bevor
man in parteitag geht das würde ja
bedeuten dass irgendjemand sagen muss
also haben uns das jahr angekommen ich
glaube auch nicht so mein ding oder ich
glaube ich schaffe es nicht mehr ich
kann nicht für meine mitbewerber
sprechen wenn die das sagen würden oder
sollten dann ist das ihre entscheidung
dann wäre es recht natürlich nein mir
ist recht dass wir jetzt einen fairen
und guten wettbewerb miteinander haben
und wir werden auf dem bundesparteitag
das tun was eine partei tun muss wir
wählen eine neue führung
und es ist das königsrecht des
parteitages darüber zu entscheiden und
das wird nicht in hinterzimmern
ausgekungelt sondern das wird auf der
offenen bühne des parteitages
entschieden spielen noch ein parka
zeigen von dem sie gesagt haben das
haben sie früher bei sich zu hause zwar
etwas kommt vielleicht können jetzt ganz
kurz zeigen ein jahr altes plakat ist
nämlich von wannen etwa stammt sie
wissen es noch jahres 1976 19 6 und 17
bundestagswahl 1976 48,6 prozent
willkommen zu hause aus der linken ecke
her was hat sie so begeistert an dem
plakat naja gut meinte das war damals
ein plakat der jungen union dass die
junge union bundesweit plakatiert hat
und das war eine war eine tolle
botschaft ein junges mädchen das ich für
die union bekämpft und mit
boxhandschuhen grünen boxhandschuhen
kämpft sie haben sich sie gelten obwohl
sie dieses plakat so toll fanden und
erzählen was sie früher für bands gehört
haben ehu und so weiter geld sie ja doch
als er der konservative geist in der
partei vor allen dingen in
gesellschaftspolitischen fragen unter
anderem bei der ehe für alle
wir schauen mal was sie
ein zitat von 2001 da haben sie der
bunten ein interview gegeben und sie
sind gefragt worden
nach berlins regierendem bürgermeister
klaus wowereit also finden sie das auch
so gut von einem schwulen regiert zu
werden in deutschlands hauptstadt dann
haben sie damals geantwortet nein
solange der sich mir nicht mehr hat ist
mir das egal
war das eine gute antwort wenn es zu
hause machen das war eine flapsige
antwort die aber ich glaube die ist
nicht beleidigend gewesen
ich würde 20 jahre später heute so was
nicht mehr formulieren
aber ich habe mit klaus wowereit auch
danach oft zu tun gehabt er hat es mir
nicht übel genommen wir sind gut
klargekommen miteinander ich glaube er
hat das sportlich genommen
aus der antwort sprechen so ganz leicht
doch gewisse vorbehalte heraus hätten
sie vorbehalte wenn heute ein schwuler
bundeskanzler würde
nein wer für sie völlig normal also ich
sage also über über die frage der
sexuellen orientierung
das geht die öffentlichkeit nichts an
solange sich das im rahmen der gesetze
bewegt und so lange es nicht kinder
betrifft an der stelle ist für mich
allerdings eine absolute grenze erreicht
ist das kein thema für die öffentliche
diskussion aber schwuler bundeskanzler
er habe mir überhaupt kein thema für
mich die stellvertretende
cdu-vorsitzende frau klöckner wenn man
kann es schon kurz über sie gesprochen
die hat diese woche gesagt na wenn die
cdu nicht selber jetzt mit blick auf die
kanzlerkandidatur ihren führungsanspruch
an meldet das hat sie bei bild gesagt
dann können wir ja als partei hier
gleich einpacken also wenn das sinngemäß
jemand dann von der cs uhr am ende macht
und wenig sagen wir wollen das selber
machen dann ist auch schluss mit lustig
sehen sie es genauso julia klöckner hat
ja etwas gemacht was ich jetzt
verschiedene ich auch immer gesagt habe
wir haben zwei mal in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik deutschland einen
kanzlerkandidaten von der csu gehabt und
beide kandidaten waren dem umstand
geschuldet dass die cdu mit ihrer
führung nicht einverstanden war und in
ihrer mehrheit der cdu einen
kanzlerkandidaten der csu wollte so ich
mache nur auf den sachverhalt aufmerksam
dass wird 2020 nach meiner einschätzung
so nicht der fall sein so und das ist
das was julia klöckner auch gesagt hat
damit ist aber auch schon alles gesagt
wir haben eine reihenfolge verabredet
die lautet die cdu wählt ihren
vorsitzenden das passiert am vierten
dezember in stuttgart und dann werden
der neue vorsitzende und der vorsitzende
csu miteinander sprechen das verfahren
besprechen möglicherweise auch über die
person sprechen und dann werden die
beiden partei vorstellen die einen
gemeinsamen vorschlag ein bisschen
klarer noch das heißt wenn man sie wählt
auf dem parteitag der delegierte der ist
die sie wählt bekommt sie dann auch als
kanzlerkandidat also noch mal ich habe
ganz großen respekt vor der csu diese
fraktionsgemeinschaft von cdu und csu
ist das wertvollste was wir als union
haben strategisch für uns unverzichtbar
und deswegen werden sie von mir nie
irgendwas in diesem zusammenhang hören
was das gleichberechtigte mitsprechen
der csu an dieser wichtigsten
personalentscheidung betrifft die wir
für das nächste jahr zu treffen haben
das machen die beiden parteivorsitzenden
nach der wahl des parteivorsitzenden der
cdu und überzeugend nach der wahl den
vorsitzenden normalerweise sie werden
mich hier zu keiner weiteren aussage
bewegen das ist einfach dem
gegenseitigen respekt geschuldet ich
weise nur auf diesen historischen
zusammenhang hin sage dass das 2020 nach
meiner einschätzung so nicht der fall
sein wird alles andere ergibt sich aus
einem fairen gleichberechtigten
miteinander von cdu und csu sie bei uns
aber zumindest herr weise ich sage es
jetzt zum presse solche dinge unnötig
schwierig es ist meine von einer
spielwiese respekt voreinander ist
manchmal schwer respekt das ist dani und
man kann nicht so da kann man ganz
großen respekt haben oder lang habe ich
will am ende will ich sie und ich habe
großen respekt vor der csu und ihrer
leistung von markus söder und seiner
leistung als ministerpräsident und
parteivorsitzender
ich habe großen respekt vor der
geschichte der cdu und deswegen werde
ich mich in diesem respekt auch mit
markus söder und asyl hat ja auch ganz
großen respekt vor allen und vorganges
deutschland gewagt und sagt mein platz
ist in bayern das ist die amerikaner
besonders klare antwort
das ist nicht nur den respekt
teilweise müssen natürlich ein feuerwerk
sehen in dem augenblick wo die csu den
kanzlerkandidaten stellt verändert sich
das gesamte gefüge von cdu und csu
miteinander und das bedenkt die csu
natürlich auch aber darüber jetzt
öffentlich zu spekulieren ist überhaupt
nicht mal ein thema wir sprechen nach
dem vierten dezember miteinander schauen
wir mal ganz kurz rein in ihre
bewerbungsrede von 218 auf dem parteitag
auf dem sie angetreten sind gegen
annegret kramp karrenbauer und jens
spahn und wo sie die rede mit diesen
worten beendet dann muss es auch
wirklich freude machen dann muss es
freude machen für unser land politisch
zu arbeiten das geht aber nur wenn es
uns auch selbst freude macht wenn wir
untereinander spaß an dieser arbeit
haben heiner geißler hat mal gesagt man
kann die menschen im lande draußen nur
begeistern wenn man sich selbst auch
begeistert ja wir müssen uns wieder ein
stück von uns selbst begeistern das geht
mit unserem vereinigungen mit 400.000
mitgliedern in der partei das geht mit
unserem bundes fachausschüssen mit dem
großen fundus an kenntnissen und
fähigkeiten die wir in unserer partei
haben liebe freundinnen und vorhin und
deshalb stehe ich heute hier diesen
auftrag möchte ich gerne annehmen in
ihrer aller namen und mit ihnen zusammen
dafür sorgen dass die cdu deutschland
die große volkspartei der mitte in
deutschland bleibt und ihren auftrag in
deutschland in europa und auf der welt
so wahrnimmt wie wir das heute
richtigerweise angela merkel für ihre
tätigkeit als parteivorsitzende gedankt
haben deshalb bitte ich um ihr vertrauen
herzlichen dank sie bitten um das
vertrauen sie haben es am ende dann
nicht von ausreichend delegierten
bekommen was wollen sie diesmal besser
machen als in dieser rede also zunächst
einmal ich habe damals fünf wochen zeit
gehabt um von 0 auf 100 zu kommen und
ich bin bei 48 prozent angekommen das
war für fünf wochen keine schlechte
leistung und viele die mir immer wieder
gesagt haben du hast nicht gut genug
geredet muss sagen die passage
jedenfalls war gut ich werde beim
nächsten mal vielleicht noch ein
bisschen mehr auf die partei eingehen
auch noch ein bisschen mehr auch auf die
aufgabe die uns im nächsten jahr
gestellt wird aber ich habe jetzt
einfach ein bisschen mehr zeit ich kann
mich um die partei kümmern ich kann mich
inhaltlich noch intensiver vorbereiten
es wird jetzt noch ein bisschen lang bis
zum 14 dezember also ich hätte nichts
dagegen gehabt wenn das jetzt schon in
diesen tagen erledigt wäre die
hochschulen ich habe 25 strand getrieben
von der rede
ja ich werde dieses mal ich werde dieses
mal weniger schreiben es wird diesmal
mehr nach stichworten geben
ich habe wahrscheinlich im beim letzten
mal vor zwei jahren zu sehr am
manuskript gehangen das werde ich
diesmal das macht eine idee könnte seien
keine steuererhöhungen zu versprechen
könnte so was in der rede stehen mit
blick auf die weiterhin arise dankend an
und denke darüber nach aber da gibt es
noch keine keine entscheidung ist ein
ganz wichtiger punkt in den letzten cdu
wahlprogramm keine steuer keine steuer
ja gut nun sind wir in einer extrem
schwierigen lage die öffentlichen
haushalte sind angespannt wie wir das
noch nie erlebt haben also könnte
diesmal anders also ja ich muss darüber
nachdenken das wird dann aber eher etwas
sein für das wahlprogramm im nächsten
jahr das wird nicht sagen für diesen
parteitag auf diesem parteitag geht es
um ein stück selbstvergewisserung der
cdu aber auch um ihre zukünftige führung
letzte frage ich weiß dass man sich ganz
ungern gedanken darüber macht schon ganz
und gar öffentlich was er hier ist wenn
das schiefgeht trotzdem sollte das
diesmal nicht klappen mit allem respekt
für alle kandidaten ist dann schluss mit
politik diese weise ich denke darüber in
der tat nicht nach ich setze auf sieg
und nicht auf platz und ich konzentriere
mich in meiner täglichen arbeit darauf
dass hinzubekommen und ich werde es auch
hinbekommen
vielen dank friedrich merz viel spaß für
den wahlkampf glaube spaß darf das auch
machen absolut doch spaß darf man
vielleicht auch lachen napoli la nation
ist endlich klar dass sie heute
unser gast waren und über viele viele
wichtige politische aktuelle politische
fragen mit uns diskutiert haben wir
wollen diese diskussion weiterführen in
berlin mit meiner kollegin bild
chefreporterin kamin amesbauer die dort
eine bunte interessante kompetente
journalistische runde bei uns hat und
eben noch einmal vertiefen wird was wir
gerade in diesem tag mit friedrich merz
erlebte am schönen abend viel spaß euch
kabine was das land richtig vielen dank
lewag wir haben hier ganz aufmerksam
zugehört und hatten auch sehr viel spaß
dabei muss ich sagen und wollen jetzt
gleich die frage analysieren wie sich
friedrich merz in diesem interview
geschlagen hat wie eine cdu unter
friedrich merz möglicherweise aussehen
könnte und die alles entscheidende frage
natürlich ob er auch kanzler kann
darüber möchte ich jetzt diskutieren mit
meiner kollegin patricia platil von bild
tv guten abend michael bröcker
chefredakteur von the pioneer und unser
stamm gas claus strunz journalist und tv
autor patricia jung weiblich modern
das ist ja so die achillesferse die
friedrich merz nachgesagt wird deswegen
jetzt gleich mal eingangs an dicht die
frage hatte dich überzeugt mich hat er
nicht überzeugt aber ich hatte auch
vorher schon nicht überzeugt denn er tut
mir viel zu wenig in für die frauenquote
hatte sich ja ganz klar auch geäußert in
welche richtung es da geht er wird für
mich immer so wie die professoren die
ich hatte in der uni in bwl die wenn man
in dem ersten semester getuschelt hat
dann gesagt haben herrschaften jetzt ist
aber mal schluss mit lustig also
irgendwie ist bei ihm immer schluss mit
lustig es wären wir am ende auch gefragt
aber mal ob in der politik gelacht
werden nach der sagte er das darf nicht
also den zusatz ja nur ich mag es nicht
also insofern thematisch aber auch vom
typ her zu ich mir da sehr schwer
also irgendwie so ein bisschen
eingestaubt aus der mottenkiste wie kam
er bei dir über wird zu sagen er hat
dich inspiriert also obwohl er ja
sozusagen jemand ist dem man von früher
kennt aus einer anderen generation einem
anderen zeitalter könnte jetzt was sagen
wirkt er trotzdem so als hätte er
irgendwie ideen visionen so zukunft
gesteuert oder hat patricia recht um
und wird sozusagen er auch so also ich
glaube an anderes zeitalter ist wirklich
gemein aber das problem von 40 messen
ist tatsächlich die projektionsfläche
die er bietet nämlich immer derjenige zu
sein der doch schon immer da ist und von
gestern und vorgestern kommen inhaltlich
hat der punkte gemacht absolut und
trotzdem glaube ich dass große probleme
und wurde im märz wird einfach sein wie
sehr wollen die delegierten wirklich die
ära von angela merkel zumindest
korrigieren reformieren oder auch ein
stück weit mit ihm brechen und er hat
heute kreide gefressen das hat man in
vielen äußerungen gesehen
er kann sich gar nicht mehr so sehr von
angela merkel abgrenzen wir das 218 noch
heute machen können und das auch gemacht
hat weil die angela merkel eben heute an
der spitze ihrer popularität ist seit 16
jahren gab es nie solche werte solche
dauerhaften werte wie jetzt in der
pandemie
das macht es für ihn schwer er ist
angetragen angetreten um mit angela
merkel zu brechen und das kann ja jetzt
nicht mehr kommunizieren weil das
eventuell gegen ihn läuft und das ist
das große problem
innerlich hat der gute punkte gemacht
für den cdu-kandidaten völlig in ordnung
doch diese produktion wird jetzt glaube
ich ein großes thema ich würde das gerne
auch noch mal an dich weitergeben
klaus hat friedrich merz vielleicht mehr
an stil problem also inhaltlich kommen
dennoch darauf zu sprechen aber ist es
vielleicht so seine ganzer sein ganzer
habitus dass er da irgendwie nicht
ankommt vor allem eben bei jungen frauen
also das ist sicherlich etwas was ihn
begleitet er wirkt immer sehr kantig
sehr bisschen von oben herab ich fand
dieses heute wenig ausgeprägt ich fand
ihn heute anders als das wahrgenommen
an manchen stellen sogar nach gerade
locker also im friedrich hat auf der
friedlichen art skala von lockerheit war
das eine cvc
normalerweise ist er viel steifer viel
noch steifer noch viel sozusagen kannte
ich ja und das ist natürlich wenn man
gewählt werden will von den menschen und
den bürgern kein vorteil
in seiner partei finde ich hatte heute
mit dem interview punkte gemacht weil er
für all diejenigen die
lediglich einen neuanfang nach angela
merkel wollen der kandidat ist er hat
kreide gefressen
das stimmt aber hat auch punkte gemacht
also es ist mir schon klar geworden dass
es mit ihm eine flüchtlingspolitik wie
die von angela merkel nicht geben wird
es ist klar geworden dass er viel viel
klarere worte finden will putin
gegenüber
es ist klar geworden welche
wirtschaftspolitik er gut findet und
welche er zu linksliberal findet jetzt
kommt er beim punkt der sein verhängnis
werden wird die cdu würde ja wenn nicht
alles täuscht kandidaten brauchen mit
dem auch die grünen sich vorstellen
können unter umständen zu koalieren
und es ist ganz sicher nicht friedrich
merz ich würde das gern auch nochmal
aufgreifen michael er hat sich auch
gestern beim niedersachsen tag der
jungen union so als antipode zu merkel
präsentiert und auch heute noch mal ganz
klare punkte gemacht vielleicht nicht
mehr ganz so klar aber doch inhaltlich
abgeseilt von der kanzlerin
während armin laschet sein
hauptkonkurrent so die sich als weiter
so kandidat präsentiert jetzt rein
strategisch was ist eigentlich klüger
also jemand der sagt mit mir kopf etwas
ganz neues oder jemand der sagt auch
alle sind doch gerade zufrieden mit der
kanzlerin
mit mir wird so weitergehen noch vor
einem jahr hätte ich wirklich gesagt die
strategie abgrenzen neue reform neuem
mut neues anpacken das was er übrigens
jahrzehntelang ja immer thematisiert hat
mangelnde führung keine entschlusskraft
keine reformeifer hat er ja alles
vorgeworfen
vor allem im jahr vielleicht wäre das
noch das programm gewesen wilfried heute
ist es das nicht mehr von friedrich merz
steht für eine politik die angela merkel
ablehnt das ist offensichtlich das weiß
natürlich auch jeder der 1000
delegierten und armin laschet sagt
tatsächlich ja weiter so mit mir gibt es
eine angela merkel 2 das sagt er
inzwischen ja als scherz aber er meint
das auch so und das hätte er vor allem
ja auch nicht machen dürfen dann wäre ja
untergegangen insofern ist angela merkel
die kontinuität nur wenn man armin
laschet wert sofern ist es auch ein
richtungskampf das wird schon knapp
glaube ich weil die cdu-delegierten
wirklich jetzt entscheiden müssen auch
die bei der jungen union die ja
tendenziell immer gegen angela merkel
waren und jetzt deswegen auch so
zugejubelt haben in hildesheim beim
niedersachsen tag die junge union der
wirtschaftsflügel können die sich
eventuell mit ihrer prof
vorm ansatz mit ihrer klartext politik
die sich so gerne wünschen da vorne im
kanzleramt können die sich durchsetzen
oder sind nicht doch auch die frauen ein
drittel der delegierten sind frauen die
ja mit friedrich mehr jetzt wirklich
egal wo man da rein hört nichts zu tun
was ist mit denen in der mittellage die
laschet leute inhaltlich nicht die
lasche fans sondern die die inhaltlich
bei laschet sind das sind auch viele
ministerpräsident das sind viele
landesverbände in niedersachsen
schleswig-holstein
die werden sich alle entscheiden müssen
ist es eine an merkel kurs oder nicht
das ist am ende die entscheiden die
können bieten was sie wollen dem
parteitag ist eine entscheidung pro oder
contra angela merkel und da stehen heute
stand jetzt man weiß nie was in den
nächsten drei monaten passiert stehen
die zeichen besser für armin laschet bei
den delegierten das glaube ich wirklich
märz ja einen man kann sagen vorteil
oder nachteil je nachdem wie man zieht
er war auf jeden fall knapp fast 20
jahre raus aus der politik geht jetzt
erstmal so als menetekel dass er keine
politische praxis hat möglicherweise
keine netzwerke das denn ich weiß wie
man taktiert oder all das was man so im
politischen handwerk braucht aber andere
sagen ja auch ist doch wunderbar haben
wir endlich mal kein berufspolitiker
nicht einen der irgendwie nur dem
bundestag von innen kennt aber nicht die
welt da draußen
und er hat ja irgendwie der karriere
hingelegt wo stehst du da findest du es
gut eigentlich dass er sozusagen eben
die welt da draußen kennengelernt hat
und vielleicht jetzt da auch
wirtschaftliches know how mit ins
kanzleramt bringen könnte oder es ist
eher nachteil dass er so lange ich finde
ich das immer von vorteil wenn man sich
auskennt wenn man den markt erlebt hat
das macht er ja auch zu themen bei sich
ich traue auch durchaus zu dass seine
seilschaften knüpfen kann networken
geben kann
ich glaube das hat er immer schon
gekonnt und das hat er nie im leben
verlernt ich will aber noch zwei punkte
sagen wie eben sich sehr im blut haben
finde ich fühlen sich der mensch märz
mir nochmal so gezeigt hat weil wir
jetzt auch gerade nochmal über die
frauen und die frauen gehen eben bei
denen er nicht so beliebt ist wie aber
den ankommt und es waren zwei punkte die
ich mir notiert hat einmal hat er
gesprochen da ging es um den
frauenanteil bei der cdu und da meinte
er wir haben ja viele männer die nicht
für die familie da sein müssen dass er
das wort müssen benutzt hat sagt
unendlich viel aus es ist für ihn weder
ein dürfen noch ein können und überhaupt
gar kein möchten also das ist wirklich
noch ein mann der aus strukturen
das heißt ich muss für die kinder da
sein das war nicht an einen wahnsinnigen
moment und dort hat sich wieder gezeigt
warum er bei frauen so unbeliebt ist
also in aus meiner sicht und das zweite
war bier über die schulschließungen
während der korona zeit gesprochen hatte
dachte ich das ist also doch ein thema
bei ihm
es geht nicht nur um die wirtschafts-
und zwar es geht ein thema was mich
interessiert mal hören also wie können
dass die kinder nachholen ja auch dass
wieder ein blöder moment es geht nur um
die leistung es gibt nur darum gehe die
kinder das nachholen können es geht
nichts über die überforderten familien
es geht nicht um die kinder die im
sozialen abseits gelandet sind an die
man gar nicht mehr angekommen ist und es
geht vor allem nicht um die kinder
sondern es geht um die leistung über das
nachholen können und genau das dafür
steht für mich märz steht ja auch so
nach dem motto vorwärts in die
vergangenheit als kandidat irgendwie
doch der vergangenheit als jemand der
mir erzählte letztens jemand sohn oder
brachte so ganz netten vergleich gut bei
lehnen
märz erinnert ihn an die frau die da im
koma die wände verschläft und dann
irgendwann später aufwacht und unter von
allen seiten vorgegaukelt wird sie ist
immer noch in der ddr oder so weiter
lebt ist märz so ein bisschen irgendwie
in der also vor 20 jahren hängen
geblieben ist es wird immer besser
mein erstes ist ein ganz großer anteil
der menschen im land so alt wie
friedrich merz und eltern und für die
ist ja natürlich nach wie vor ein
ankerpunkt sofern sie konservativ von
der mitte sich selber verankert sehen
oder dort politik gemacht die kinder ja
sager höchsten naja die kinder erst
erobert oder opa der kinder die jetzt in
der kita sind das ist ja wahr
aber was haben wir denn hier jetzt für
eine fiese formen von alltagsrassismus
als würde ein mann der 60 ist und wenn
der kanzler würde 65 ist keine ahnung
davon haben was im land vor sich geht es
das sehe ich anders
ich finde auch ist er sympathisch dass
jemand der auf die schulen blick nicht
so auch die kirchen und die muss man
sich kümmern sondern sagt wir sind die
looser in der digitalisierung und der zu
erkennen gibt dass er das verändern will
das ist doch dass shell unglaubwürdig
geradeauslauf und konnte sword
digitalisierung aus seinem mund ich erst
einmal
so jetzt wirklich das radio ist am alter
festmachen finde ich das fast so schlimm
wie frauenfeindlichkeit ich würde sagen
es ist sozusagen
es zählt doch am ende wo für eine steht
und ob er dann wort hält und das traue
ich einen früheren manager der
wirtschaft schon zu dass er die
digitalisierung in deutschland
vorantreibt dieses früherer manager der
wirtschaftskrise sein ist aber auch ein
nachteil wenn man nämlich friedrich merz
googelt dann kommen als erstes zwei
suchbegriffe einmal vermögen und einmal
blackrock also das heißt die menschen
sähen ihn als einen superreichen
heuschrecken manager das wird sozusagen
wenn er sich zur wahl stellt den bürgern
kein vorteil sein
ich glaube ich habe oder ich bin mir
sicher ich habe selten in letzter zeit
so viel sinnvolle dinge in einer stunde
aus einem politiker sprechen hören wie
heute es ist nur der falsche mann der
sagt es ist es michael stich phänomen
michael stich waren genauso guter
tennisspieler wie boris becker aber eben
der kühle der denker der ohne herz der
ohne passion der ohne bauch der ohne
becker faust gerhard schröder waren
politiker mit becker faust friedrich
merz ist michael stich gewinnt
vielleicht wie bilden aber keiner es
geht uns nicht ums alter sondern dafür
wofür er stehe
darum wurde ja wofür sich offenbar dass
manche so anschauen deswegen michael ist
das muss man das muss man ihm das schon
mal respekt zollen dass man sagt er war
so lange nicht da aber man weiß jetzt
schon sehr sehr klar wofür er steht er
hat sehr klare antworten geliefert beim
thema flüchtlinge
doch auch sehr klar bei russland also in
eine eindeutigkeit die man ja sonst von
anderen kannten kandidaten er vermisst
also mal nach so viel passion von claus
strunz die einordnung des delegierten
ist doch kann dieser mensch da vorne mir
mein mandat wieder bringen oder mir mein
neues mandat ermöglicht das ist mein job
sicher haben wir die entscheidende frage
ist ja nicht wie ich den finden oder wie
wir als beobachten sondern was sagen die
delegierten wir analysieren das ich auch
nicht glaube dass die delegierten sagen
parteiprogramme und profil muss
zusammenpassen und diese glaubwürdig da
die du schon zurecht auch angesprochen
hast hat er bei bestimmten themen nicht
ich glaube heute seine sicht richtig
gute digitale politik machen will
aber er hat die glaubwürdigkeit weder
bei modernen männern und vielleicht auch
modernen arbeitszeit freizeit
entscheidet und wie organisiere ich die
familie wie mach ich bildungspolitik
gleichberechtigung diese ganzen fragen
hat er nie auf dem schirm gehabt man
kann sich die bücher ja durch lederball
armin laschet hatte wir haben sie mir
gerade von oder wiesen an denn die haben
ganz viele gäste ist noch eine idee
heißt lieber herr
die frage ist doch ist er ja der
glaubwürdigkeit seiner bücher behandeln
aktienkultur und nicht moderne
familienpolitik ich kenne diese bücher
alle und armin laschet hat zumindest
einen einzigen vorteil er hat in seiner
politik in nordrhein-westfalen bestimmte
dinge bewiesen nämlich einfach wie er
zum beispiel ein ressort strukturiert ob
es ein ob der vize ministerpräsidenten
kita minister ist oder ob es der
finanzminister dass nur ein kleines
beispiel das heißt armin laschet kann
immer auch seine regierungsbilanz
verweisen und den leuten dort sage hört
man erstens habe ich eine schwarz gelbe
regierung das doch eure wunsch wurde
zweitens habe ich aber auch kita und
integration so aufgestellt er kann auch
seine regierungsbilanz verweisen
friedrich merz hat das problem dass er
viel versprechen muss und man immer
gleichzeitig die bilder da drin hat ja
wo weißt du das bist du da glaubwürdig
und ich glaube dass am ende ist
entscheidung kann man hin zutrauen dass
er das hinbekommt trotz dieser langen
politik ab das finde ich schon ich wenn
der seite steige wir brauchen wirklich
dringend mehr seiteneinsteiger aber was
ich dann auch nicht verstehe ist wenn du
seiteneinsteiger bis und dann musst du
dich mehr um die partei kümmern
dann musst du zu den vereinigungen gehen
dann musst du allianzen schmieden
bündnis habe das hat er 218 alles nicht
gemacht friedrich merz sich wird das nie
vergessen am abend vorher die
delegierten besprechung er saß unserem
tisch die leute kamen zu ihm durften
hallo sagen während sparen und co und
andere geht kam kaum bauer
unterstützergruppen organisierten von
tisch zu tisch gingen überzeugten
menschen wählen menschen und das hat
armin laschet und jens spahn besser
drauf jetzt will wenn ich mir die
netzwerk im moment in der cdu an schaue
ich kann mich täuschen ich glaube so
dass das immer so ein bisschen so fertig
das problem war ich bin doch gut ich hab
doch ahnung welt mich aber dazu gehört
eben auch empathie auf die leute zugehen
was auf jeden fall immer wieder von
friedrich merz gesagt wird ist es kein
teamplayer und das riecht ja auch dafür
also erwartet bis die leute auf ihn
zugehen er geht aber nicht rum also so
diese gewisse soziale kompetenz die man
ja doch als kanzler vielleicht auch
braucht wird zu sagen dass dieses
menschliche vielleicht seine größte
schwäche sein klasse ich genauso ich
glaube das menschliche ist seine größte
schwäche entfernt
man sich das als tennisspieler dann
vergleichen gerade durchaus erlauben
kann weil es eben nur ein tennisspieler
ist geht es in der politik eben genau
darum entsprechende erstmal nur für den
delegierten aber irgendwann sprechen
will womöglich von einem kanzler und da
brauchen die menschen jemand menschen
wählen menschen das war ein toller satz
genau das ist es als ob jemand wie
angela merkel die sich um kitas kümmert
die von familien kann das nicht
vergleichen kann das zu holen also ganz
einfach nicht vorstellen ich glaube
friedrich merz wird es nicht weil wenn
die delegierten wie du richtig
analysiert die wahl haben zwischen dem
ganz kannte ich ihn mit den inhalten die
in den namen aber der kühle von oben
herab mensch irgendeinem plattling mit
randloser brille also röttgen hast du
übrigens wieder gefallen dann
entscheiden sie sich sozusagen für den
mit dem man was anfangen kann für
laschet der also märz wird es nicht
werden mir gefällt nur nicht sozusagen
unser starker ausrichtung auf das
drumherum statt auf die aussagen und in
den aussagen hat er als konservative
politiker heute an geglänzt aber mit
meinen punkt vorn ist was bringt es mir
als cdu delegierten ihn zu wählen wenn
es am ende zu einer polarisierung kommt
das ist ja das narrativ von armin
laschet da hat er nicht ganz unrecht
wenn ihr armin wenn ihr friedrich merz
welt liebe cdu-delegierten kann
rot-rot-grün realistisch sein dass es so
stark ist negativ was demnach städte
lager natürlich gespielt wird das ist
ein strategisches motiv aber am ende ist
es auch als als cdu-delegierten motiv
ich möchte nicht dass dieses land rot
rot grün regiert wird also kann ich
nicht den willen der die richtig nach
oben
meine sorge um mögliche koalitionen
angesprochen hat welche machtoption hat
merz schwarz gelb ist jetzt nicht
wirklich in sicht weiter also schwarz
grün ist ja eher so dass realistische
kann man sich märz in einer
schwarz-grünen koalition vor sich aber
er könnte sich aussuchen bei dem es
eigentlich nur schwarz schwarz möglich
ich kann mir das wirklich schwer
vorstellen wann machen alles mit auf den
weg machen vielleicht doch alles ohne
würde er sich analoge richtung grünen
bewegen was glauben wir
ich würde schon sagen was ein kurz ideen
gibt mir meine themen finanzen
wirtschaft innen und macht über spitze
was ihr wollt aber friedlich und es wird
wunderbar mit den grünen regieren und
die grünen übrigens auch hauptsache sie
kommen endlich an die regierung doch das
ist nicht das thema die frage jetzt
wirklich etwas was die wähler was die
delegierten wollen aber friedrich merz
würde schwarz grünen genau so hinkriegen
wie wahrscheinlich glaube aber die
grünen würden wenn man schon bei
machtoptionen sind sobald grün rot rot
geht was ja übrigens wahrscheinlicher
ist als rot grün rosa oder sowas da
müssen wir älteren uns erst noch daran
gewöhnen das ist jetzt ein grün so droht
das zeitalter
sobald das sind schnippeln möglich ist
machen sie lieber das als mit friedrich
mehr dass schwarz-grün islam hat sich
dann selbst dann kann uns den punkt
finde ich schon valide wenn märz
antreten würde als kanzlerkandidat
steigen die chancen für grün rot roten
absolut hat er denn er sagt ja selbst
sein großes ziel ist auf jeden fall all
die verloren gegangenen wähler ins
nichtwählerlager die grünen vor allem
die fdp wähler jetzt aktuell
zurückzuholen hat er da chancen seht ihr
da wirklich potenzial dass sein kandidat
friedrich merz wieder mehr die
klassischen alten cdu ja für die cdu
mobilisiert ja ich glaube schon die
frage ist wie viele sind es die frage
ist einfach schlicht wie viele sind ist
und dann gibt es jetzt ganz allein
demoskopen fragen gesagt die mitte cdu
verliert zu viel wenn friedrich merz
kandidieren als dass man im rechten rand
holen kann
die anderen sagen du kannst dort ganz
viel holen
diejenigen die afd wählen aber nichts
mit rechten zu tun haben wollen wobei
das ja auch fragwürdig ist so etwas zu
kommen
ich glaube tatsächlich die letzten mal
auch die kommunalwahl haben gezeigt dass
ein mitte kurs mit einbindung von
konservativen rennen ich denke mal so
ein wolfgang bosbach oder herbert reul
in nordrhein westfalen dass das auch
helfen kann die afg kleinsten nicht nur
der scharfkantige flüchtlings kritische
kurs eines spitzenkandidaten
es gibt verschiedene wege die afg klein
zu behalten anstatt sie zumindest nicht
groß werden dass die nordrhein westfalen
ich glaube auch friedrich merz würde
viele zurückholen von denen absolut die
frage ist ob so ein saal und größer ist
schwierig zu beantworten ich lange das
schon also ich glaube dass er genau die
die jetzt so ein bisschen in richtung
gehen
die immer konservativ gewählt haben die
etwa aber sagen ach und mit der
flüchtlingspolitik ist hat die merkel
nicht gut gemacht und da du ja heute
auch noch einmal ganz klar akzente
gesetzt
um genau eben auch die rhein zu holen
und ich glaube dafür also ich habe viel
gegen ihn gesagt aber ich glaube dafür
ist tatsächlich der mann aber inhaltlich
war stärker eigentlich als die anderen
kandidaten der bislang im um den cdu
vorsitz im rennen sind oder also klarer
klare aber das leicht schließe mich
jetzt diesem diesen denken an was ist
denn eigentlich erfolgsversprechend
innerhalb der partei und innerhalb des
delegierten gremiums das ist vielleicht
genau der fehler
die menschen sind ja seit 16 jahren auch
in der union gewohnt dass sie
wischiwaschi kriegen und das haben sie
sozusagen gemacht und wenn armin laschet
es weiter fortsetzt mögen sie es
vielleicht auch in zukunft hin wir sind
vielleicht kein land das klare ansagen
gebrauchen kann oder mag ihn weil er ja
auch schon auf dem weg war die klage
heute schon wie das ist wiederum ich
habe für gut ist übrigen gesagt aber das
ist vielen schreien punkt dass er dann
nicht dass er dann nicht auch dass er
dann doch nicht ganz auf den tisch haut
und sagen das war falsch und ich selbst
er macht hier das neue prinzip der
ethischen demobilisierung wie ich noch
nicht gehört habe also die themen die
schwierig sein könnte man sie moral
betrifft in der flüchtlinge bloß nicht
groß kochen aber auch im persönlichen
als ich auch ein genau
nicht weil sie vom beleihungswert dann
müsste ich mich ja müsste ich ja zeigen
wo ich wirklich mehr lager wohl über das
die formulierung nachgedacht hat wir das
kategorisieren soll wir zu angela merkel
schnell ich meinte stvg hin wirklich
gedemütigt hat und aus praktisch aus der
verantwortung gejagt hat ich glaube wenn
ich mich recht entsinne zweimal
ich habe ein gutes auskommen mit angela
mich sprechen miteinander das ist eine
sensationelle formulierung für die dicke
kommt echt ins repertoire weil die heißt
ja eigentlich eigentlich kann ich die
frau nicht leiden und sie mich nicht
aber jetzt muss ich halt ein bisschen
nett sein damit ich nicht alle anhänger
vergrault hat dieses jahr wieder
gassenhauer ja das sind genau solche
vokabeln die wird die wünsche ich mir
halt weniger in der politik ein gutes
auskommen auskommen denke ich erst mal
an geld ich habe gutes auskommen
friedrich habe das wort einkommen nicht
leiden sagt er offen zugegeben erst
millionär also insofern redet er auch
darüber gerne
mittelstand millionen also egal aber
genau dass uns solche wo haben die em
von denen ich weniger möchte also warum
kann man nicht sagen ja gut in der
vergangenheit öfter mal geknirscht aber
jetzt sind wir gemeinsam auf einem guten
weg weil ich will die zugesagte ganz oft
ohne zukunft geredet in der unbedingt
schauen möchte und das möchte ich jetzt
gerne machen und dann bemühen wir uns
auf beiden seiten warum muss man so ein
verschwurbelt des awards benutzen um
eine beziehung zu beschreiben völlig
recht es ist schlicht die wahrheit jeder
in der cdu weist das wie oft ja auch
friedrich merz man muss sich nur mal
reden vom cdu wirtschaftsrat rausholen
von voll ein oder zwei oder drei jahren
das ist ganz klare scharfe inhaltliche
und persönliche kritik an und die art
und weise wie sie politiker friedrich
merz steht für völlig andere politik wie
man kann das sehr gut oder schlecht
finden aber er steht für das gegenteil
von angela merkel das weiß auch hier und
auch menschlich
da will ich meinen zwei enden oder
vielleicht weiß ich nicht ich kenne
arbeite gar nicht so gut als dass man
das menschliche beurteilt wenn da aber
inhaltlich hatte einen völlig anderen
vorstellung zum beispiel von allein in
jamaika koalition ich erinnere mich dass
er da vor zwei jahren gesagt hat
unerträglich banal wie die das da gebaut
und geführt hat dass das ist ja
dilettantisch und solche sätze also wo
er ja auch ziemlich rum geschmuggelt
also inhaltlich sonst wahrer relativ
klar aber wo er wirklich ist sehr
geschmuggelt hat und sich nicht
festlegen wollte war bei der
kanzlerkandidatur
also das ist ihm irgendwie nicht so
wirklich über die lippen gekommen dass
er als cdu-vorsitzender dann wirklich
auch die kanzlerkandidatur will warum
nicht ich habe sie sich verstanden also
heute irgendwo gelesen dass er dabei der
jungen union hat irgendwie sagt da wird
es nicht also da hat er schon mal
ausgeschlossen dass es der csu mann wird
es dann dort wiederholen aber warum man
nicht sagen kann also indirekt hat das
ja immer gesagt also aber keine ahnung
ich hatte eine böse ist wenn der marke
soda nach seinem auftritt niedersachsen
bekommen ich habe es auch nicht
verstanden weil als cdu-vorsitzender bei
knapp 40 teilweise in umfragen muss man
noch den anspruch einer klar werde ich
cdu-vorsitzender werde dann habe ich
erstmal erstzugriffsrecht
unwahrscheinlich dass auch in angriff
nehmen ich möchte gerne kanzler werden
das machen aber er kennt er es heute
nicht diesen satz so ich setze auf sieg
und nicht auf platz und ich glaube
kanzlerfrage irgendwie mit ein und ich
glaube damit denkt denkt will er
eigentlich alles abdecken aber klar
äußerte sich immer dieses fußballspiel
analog das nicht so gar nicht
nachgedacht
er ist friedrich merz seien hasardeure
wenn man genauer darüber nachdenkt
verwendet einen vergleich aus dem
pferderennen über seine eigene zukunft
muss sich heute noch darüber nach was du
dich wenden leider sehr viele
und das wo er ja soviel jetzt wirklich
riskiert alles alles wirklich aufgegeben
hat für diesen einen posten und sein
kann ehrlich sagen interessant dass wir
also sozusagen die ganze zeit was ist
denn jetzt eigentlich quasi für
deutschland das beste
und wenn ich jetzt über alles nachdenken
haben wir alle schon aufgegeben eine
bürgerlich konservative koalition die
das land führt es geht eigentlich nur
noch darum es ist jamaika ist es schwarz
grün ist spd vorsitzende auch sagen
leute bist du was ich stehe dafür ich
mache schwarz-gelb ich möchte eine
bürgerlich konservative mehrheit in
deutschland und das soll sich jetzt die
rot rot aber wieder grün vor uns noch
mal zusammen tun amila wonach mit den
kommunisten deutschland regiert armin
laschet macht haben wir eine schwarz
gelbe regierung hat ihnen immer ich
würde an friedrich merz halle vorsichtig
sein mit so einem bekenntnis hat eine
schwarze in deutschland die einzige ihm
fehlen nur noch die grüne jamaika und so
kommt es auch nicht halten kann ja sein
aber auf jeden fall sagt sogar eine
wunschkoalition
aber vielleicht gut nicht märz der dann
auch sagen sollen sind waren 38 bis fünf
jahre für abwegig aber ich will noch mal
wir sagen was man ein punkt ist wenn ich
mich stark genug fühle die wähler da fdp
zurückzuholen zur cdu die frühere cdu
gewählt haben wenn ich mich stark genug
fühle alle wirtschaftsliberalen in
deutschland zu mobilisieren wenn ich
mich stark und gemüse fdp
es braucht auch nur sechs prozent wenn
ich mich stark genug fühlen um
schwarz-gelb zu machen
warum gibt es eigentlich niemanden mehr
der sich das vorstellen mag das wird
deutschland haben in einer bürgerlich
konservativen koalition die dieses land
regiert nach bürgerlich konservativen
vorstellungen sondern das alles schon
für links aus und ist ein ganzes stück
kleinvach antwort weil es einfach zu
früh ist es der parteitag ist noch nicht
er ist noch nicht mal vor es ist wenn er
sich jetzt hinstellen würde uns über
mögliche koalition würde
während du sagst was du dir wünschst ja
analysieren wir dass das ist aber ich
wünsche doch ich sage den fünf prozent
fdp es einfach sehr wenig sehr sehr
wenig im bund soll die nacht inklusive
337 plötzlich ruhig weil er stand
langweilig wird nochmal kurz ein stern
und analysiert was denn sein könnte wenn
merz dann wirklich cdu-chef wird also
jetzt rein hypothetisch wie würde denn
eine cdu unter friedrich werden aussehen
und sich vielleicht weiblicher
entwickeln mit weniger frauen r2 ja
gesagt ja ich möchte dann im kabinett so
gerne halbe-halbe aber frauenquoten das
möchte er nicht es könnte ja das ist ja
auch ein toller satz zur diskriminierung
von männern führen
also mein größtes augenmerk sollte es
soweit kommen und heute er dann nach dem
cdu womöglich auch ganz klar sein wie
schaut das kabinett aus kommt überhaupt
eine frauenquote lassen und tiefer
ansetzen kommt eine frauenquote
ich glaube nicht dass mit dem programm
mit märz was sind die wahlkampf was ich
glaube ich würde natürlich wenn er nicht
völlig bescheuert ist den satz sagen wir
brauchen 50 prozent parität im kabinett
genau die minister die für die er dann
fahren wurde 50 50 wie erst dann mit der
frauenquote weiter geht ok wird man
sehen
aber ich glaube das programm von
friedrich merz ist natürlich eine extrem
auf die wirtschaftspolitische erneuerung
des landes ausgerichtetes programm
ihn interessieren die
gesellschaftspolitischen auch
von dirk anger zu recht angenehm einfach
nicht so es ist nicht so sein herzblut
ich sage ja nicht dass er deswegen
daniel vielleicht eine rückständige
politik und das ist nicht dein herz und
dafür steht ja nicht da kennt er sich
nicht so aus insofern kommt es schon
darauf an welche menschen eher
präsentieren würde die mit ihm in dieses
team hinein und ich glaube dass es
wirklich noch mal entscheiden
unbelastet an einen mann nominiert der
heißen sparen aber wer dahinter kommt
wissen wir auch noch nicht ich glaube
dass völlig märz durchaus da wenn er im
november so schrittweise teammitglieder
präsentiert noch mal eine chance hat
sich anders darzustellen weil er weiß
auch die schwächen die defizite die er
hat muss er ausgleichen im team sowie
das für uns alle in teams gilt also
insofern ist das rallye noch gar nicht
gemacht er hat ja jemand jüngeren
angekündigt
vielleicht ist ich glaube dass frauen
thema wird ihnen durch diese ganzen wahl
und dann möglicherweise auch im
wahlkampf begleiten und das wird am ende
immer wieder ganz merkwürdig es zehn
vorbringen so wie auch übrigens heute
als seine in einfluss seine junge
kollegin aus der cdu eine wie ich fand
wirklich bemerkenswerte rede und
ansprache gehalten hat und ihn auch
kritisiert hat da natürlich sozusagen
eine riesen chance liegen lassen auf sie
eingehen können hätte sagen können und
am ende verspreche ich ihnen ich trete
auch an um frauen wie sie zu überzeugen
und lassen sie uns sprechen was wir
besser machen müssen
das hat er irgendwie so leicht da bin
ich bei dir das wirkt so als würde das
so leicht zur kenntnis nehmen und sagen
also junge frau kennen sie noch ein
bisschen an die uni zu sprechen das ist
natürlich ganz schlecht ist kompakt für
dich erdäpfel kopf ja also es gibt
äußerung ist der cdu die nicht viel mit
empathie zu tun haben wenn es um den
umgang mit demenz geht er hat vielleicht
liegt er sagt ich habe irgendwann selber
mag das liegt auch an der größe dass es
immer so wirkt als würde er von oben
herab reden kann man natürlich so
definieren ich glaube dahinter spielte
er weiß viel lernt viel erlebt er hat
natürlich in der wirtschafts und
finanzpolitik echte erfahrung und er
spürt man spürt dass als sein
gesprächspartner relativ schnell wenn er
sich überlegen führt in der politik
natürlich nicht so die allerbeste
eigenschaft wenn man den menschen
gegenüber dessen idee man ja immer so
tut als sei es die beste die man gerade
hier gehört hat
natürlich gewinnen so jetzt sagt man ja
immer friedrich merz ist eine der korona
verlierer weil nicht jede teil der
exekutive und deswegen jetzt so ein
bisschen vom radar verschwunden aber
könnte er vielleicht noch zu einem
großen chor ohne gewinner werden bei
seine themen jetzt an fahrt aufnehmen
also eben solide haushaltspolitik
finanzen steuern wirtschaft ankurbeln
usw
ja sicher das liegt ein bisschen dran
wie sieg ohne entwickelt das ist der
gemeinde mit allen die da jetzt
sozusagen auf der bühne stehend auf der
politischen bühne stehen ich finde aber
auch da hätte er sie etwas mehr mut zu
trauern können das eine oder andere
regierungshandeln deutlicher zu
kritisieren insbesondere mit blick auf
die wirtschaft insbesondere mit blick
auf das wiederanspringen der wirtschaft
also ich glaube mit dem lockdown der
hinter uns liegt haben sich alle
inzwischen als haben wir irgendwie
überstanden
arrangiert aber wie kommen wir jetzt
eigentlich zurück das sind ja doch
wirklich bedrohliche angst machende
zahlen aus der deutschen wirtschaft zu
vermelden
da müsste er in den nächsten wochen noch
einen deutlicheren narrativ also erneut
deutlich negativ wenn also die punkte
benennen die ihn wirklich umtreiben er
will der kandidat von außen sein mit dem
was neues kommt neuer aufbruch erzählt
ihm da der mut so wirklich in die vollen
zu gehen ja er ist da glaube ich einfach
sehr verkopft und für mut gehört ja auch
immer so ein bisschen emotionen noch
dazu ich glaube das ist bei ms
sonderlich ausgeprägt und ich glaube es
gibt halt eben einen gewinner von corona
und das ist markus söder und ja der
punkt das sind alles fragen die wir uns
stellen werden aber dennoch wenn du in
den zeiten von kuren als politiker
gewinnen möchtest dann brauchst du eben
dann musste dieser mensch des volkes
sein dann musst du jemand sein der das
gefühl vermittelt ich nehme euch an die
hand ich helfe all das hat merz eben
nicht ist es denkbar dass merz ganz
knapp gewinnt so ungefähr da legt wo ak
vor rund zwei jahren raus gekommen ist
also 52 prozent die hälfte der partei
aber eigentlich unzufrieden mit ihm ist
und ihn drängt ihn aufzugeben oder
abzugeben wäre das denkbar dass er
wirklich ein markus söder dann das feld
überlasse ich glaube die erst mal die ko
runde
kann es noch gar nicht geschrieben das
land mit den meisten neuinfektionen ist
bayern
ob markus söder da so raus geht aus
einer debatte in den dezember hinein als
der unangefochtene corona bekämpfer wage
ich zu bezweifeln
genauso wie armin laschet vielleicht
gerade der ewige user bleiben wird bei
den zahlen jetzt nun mal corona bilanz
etwas friedrich merz betrifft er denkt
ja er hat immer noch die 48 prozent das
ist aus meiner sicht sei eine falsche
strategische entscheidung er hat nicht
mehr die 48 der damals hatte als
newcomer als als als auch wieder freche
reformbereit der neben angekommen kamen
auch wirklich ja auch ein antipode war
diese 48 hatte aus meiner sicht jetzt
nicht mehr obwohl er glaubt er braucht
nur noch zwei
ich glaube er fängt bei null an und bei
null fällt jemand eben erst recht an der
in der kohlepolitik nichts zeigen konnte
aber auch nichts falsch machen
einverstanden
er konnte nicht zeigen was ich vermisse
ist weil du hast recht angesprungen ist
eine wirtschafts und finanzpolitische
klarheit eigentlich wo es einen dieser
deutschlandplan von friedrich merz den
er vorlegen können und sagen ich sag ich
jetzt mal ich will euch nur mal sagen wo
ich mein land hinführen würde wenn
nämlich wer da könntest du alles
durchdeklinieren über alles schon
irgendwann mal ein buch geschrieben
ich weiß es nicht so richtig wo er hin
will und diesen plan vermisst nicht bei
ihm und bei armin laschet er kann immer
sagen na ja ich sag ich was ich will
ich habe den leuten das war das was ich
mache herbert reul hier in den dreck
wühlt da sehr abgelenkt und hier machen
wir eine kita in den kita politik mit
joachim stammt die serie sehr
fortschrittlichen modell ist aber wir
noch eine rückführung politik mit herrn
rolle die sehr hartes er kann ja auch
immer fand auf das verweisen was in
seinem land nach friedrich merz kann das
nicht deswegen braucht man diesen plan
was will er machen mit dem land habt ihr
fehlt aber vielleicht kommt er ja auch
allen ecken hier eine schnelle
abschlussrunde was ist die größte stärke
und die größte schwäche von friedrich
merz
die größte stärke ist
wirtschaftskompetenz und gradlinigkeit
wenn er die handbremse löst und die
größte schwäche ist dass er überhaupt
kein schlag bei frauen hat verträgt sehr
leid tut sie das ähnlich
darüber noch eine andere große schwächen
des immer einer meinung sind ist es
kommt doch soweit ja also ich habe
inhaltlich hat das haben auch heute
gesehen sind sehr viele große
stärken da in der finanzpolitik in der
wische da kennt er sich aus das kann er
und ich glaube da ist auch glaubhaft
dass frauen ein problem hast du
angesprochen und ich glaube sie ein
zweites großes problem ist so eine art
arroganz wieder rüber kommt also und das
zieht sich eben nicht zwei frauen durch
sondern das wird vielleicht auch den
einen oder anderen mann abschrecken
michael ich glaube die größte stärke es
wirklich sein mut alleine jetzt wieder
anzutreten immer wieder sich ins spiel
zu bringen und tatsächlich auf
politische vorschläge gemacht zu haben
die sehr mutig sind und seine schwäche
ist und bleibt diese fehlende empathie
dieses nicht zu hören wollen was
vielleicht auch ihm intellektuell
unterlegen cdu menschen im gerne sagen
wollen also diese fehlende emotionen die
wir möglicherweise im interview auch
etwas vermisst haben die hatten wir auf
jeden fall hier umso mehr vielen dank
für diese sehr angeregte diskussion und
das waren die richtigen fragen am
sonntagabend uns gibt's auch nächste
woche wieder einen schönen abend noch
[Musik]